oh yes live stream offline see yeah
offline
hold on Mark it's not live on your
channel I don't see it well there it is
oh god oh Tyler fix it Tyler fix it fix
it Tyler Tyler fix it
I wanted to hear us with us all right
hello everybody Welcome to the
distractible uh live podcast guess what
look at these guys
for you
oh we need like some feedback on what
what you're doing oh yeah what's
happening all right all right oh you
zoomed in on me when I was just wait
yeah no put put the oh yeah we hold on
technical difficulties the Fourth Man in
the Discord is having some trouble here
we uh put the OBS over so we can see we
don't need to see the live feed that's a
good delay come on
let's go now I can remember now
that's really like
all right so uh welcome everybody this
is a big surprise I know I haven't
uploaded all week and I know this is
like out of the blue and I didn't
announce this at all and I didn't tell
anybody that this was going to be
happening and this is probably the
moment where people would probably zoom
in on my face
don't matter hey look I know I didn't
say a thing I know I haven't uploaded a
thing I know that everyone is shocked to
see us all here but yes it is absolutely
100 true we have not seen each other in
five years and I know you
five years five years
yeah take that Bob is the audio okay
good that ain't working
either way we have not seen each other
in five years because not only did covet
happen but the last time that we talked
about even doing a podcast in general
was on a rooftop in the middle of
Australia and I'm happy to say this is
the official reunion of the Markiplier
you're welcome tour and it's the end of
the tour
this is the last stop but this is that
we haven't done the performance yet yeah
they missed it oh what a show it has
been but there's more for you to see not
all about me
I don't I don't even I never learned the
words to that because it was never
pertinent for me that part was just
step step
I know right very few people you
probably know what this is but I like we
went on tour once
um pull up uh the logo for the you're
welcome tour quick quick quick
for this why don't you prefer this we
prefer this we prefer this
perfectly
all right we're on this yeah uh we don't
know who the mysterious fourth person in
the Discord is
um it's history to all of us even to us
right now and right here in this moment
we don't know it is but thankfully all
the members wow this is how he's doing
it guys holy crap
the mics are not working are they not uh
but there's no audio dead ass lie that
must be a lie I definitely see it coming
through move that so we can see so we
could see it huh
it's working you guys are idiots you
fool yeah they wouldn't know see they
said midriff I said midriff and they
know exactly what they're trying to
prank us they said mysterious which is
something do them on Bob right now
wait
[Applause]
[Laughter]
me wait me hey Bob
[Applause]
oh man this is uh too far I thought you
were gonna say you
dude the mic is coming also through the
the camera
wait what no camera mics
dude you can tell there's the most
professional setup I've ever had it's
horrible quality I don't care turn off
the camera likes I don't see what you're
wanting him to do no no no no no no why
is it only on Bob
what's happening get it on us yeah there
we go oh God I'm sorry everybody we'll
fix it we'll fix it we'll fix it we'll
fix it I don't even where is the camera
like oh no it's all on the same track I
think hello Tyler doesn't know how to
fix that I would we will invent you want
me to fix it yeah I don't know how to
fix it for everyone hang on I can fix
this
oh God Bob you were just on all three
cameras you're amazing it's proof it's
proof
this is slightly differently laid out
than mine give me a sec
yep
um
I have no idea which Audio Oh no those
are muted anyway all the Sony cams are
muted yeah that's why I'm trying to
figure out how are they how do you think
they're outputting then there must be
one extra mic into the mixer guys hold
on this is
part of the show yes oh what a show it
is currently and there's more for you to
see these four we're gonna be here for a
long while yeah we're gonna give away
wait wait hold on whose mom are we doing
I have an idea Mark uh wait shut up Mark
yeah
well wait wait yell hey I'm assuming to
Guess that that's the one we want off
ah yeah
does it sound better now
you don't know I think it was something
like at least someone had headphones and
was listening
oh my God
Tyler had headphones literally sitting
there the whole time monitoring it
I'm honoring now
okay then is it better it sounds good
is it good oh no yeah so it was the it
was the spare mic that was running yeah
it wasn't the camera oh
okay is it all good did I mute the right
one it's better yes okay that's this how
did you why are you why are you like
this it's like on me
I have problems guys all right tell us
about them
yeah
which side do I look on uh your ladder
you won't
uh well first of all I can't poop
in like a week and a half they sold
pills and tapeworms for that they sell
tapeworms I've been trying to catch one
there's probably someone does I just go
sit handsless in puddles outside hoping
there's a tapeworm in there looking
forward can you buy tapeworms yes
so much more food if I had a tapeworm
you do not need to eat more food man do
you eat it we're about to go have a
whole show with our dinner when we go
eat Fogo later
oh which camera I looked at the web
camera I keep looking at the TV being
like yeah hold on how is your audio
still bad I'm literally looking like I'm
listening it sounds like
like audio is still bad
I don't know how to fix that that's
coming through just the mat the mics
what did we do without the output of the
street
do I need to mess with the stream doing
anything I got it put it on Wade
camera
all right wait you got this okay I got
this I'm here too but uh yo use your
show now oh okay we'll welcome everybody
to the Wade show you should listen to
distractible It's a podcast the three of
us are on which is much more
professionally done than our live stream
we're there the screen on my face
I need to see myself in order to talk
it's a problem I have life's true life
story
um what is there to say uh no pressure
no I feel a lot of pressure
welcome to
twitch.youtube.tv.com
Markiplier close I guess everybody our
normal streaming site
for podcasts
food yeah food we're gonna eat some food
whatever I don't know what to say I just
a result of like looking at chat and
praying that someone throws me a little
worm yeah also you guys should be
guessing in the chat we actually have a
mysterious fifth member in here who is
the fifth member
we'll never tell you but they exist in
this room and they don't have a
microphone so you'll have to guess
without any info you get no
no thing to help
Voldemort yes you got it
even oh it's probably Ethan could Ethan
say hello he could be standing behind
any of these couches you know we never
know if he's not Ethan say hello to Chad
hello my cranky crew see it's him that's
what he talks like
is anybody listening to the stream you
you have headphones no I'm listening to
what's currently happening no not what's
broadcasting on the street
still sounds chunky still sounds junky
chunky why is it Junkie
guys
listening all right uh uh wait why
should they listen to
Washington distractible well because of
great quality content like this yeah
really talk about kind of whatever I
don't know circle's fun it's kind of
like us hanging out and then getting to
be there for our stream talkiness stuff
why do you think they should listen to
distractible I think they should listen
to distractible because uh even though
Wade complains a lot he gets the he gets
his dues finally after all the years of
Drunk Minecraft
and all of the people shouting shut up
Wade at him randomly in public which
literally happens so much more than you
might even guess I go to a restaurant
try to order food they're like shut up
wait I was asking someone else he
finally gets to shine on the podcast and
we can't even talk about it because you
win a lot okay you complain about how
much we win because we did win at the
beginning but you're you're leading the
wins now right I think I don't know I'll
take it anyone out there on the
subreddit is there a concurrent
up-to-date compiler who is the
winningest
no audio
hold on why why
would what about this what about this
worse someone someone helped
same sound
it does something
I mean it doesn't sound awful it just
sounds like not
something I don't know what that
we should do an RV around the world
podcast dude I've been pitching I think
we should just do
top gear but as us guys who
know very little about cars actually and
just get a coffee or something didn't we
talk about doing that drawing a penis
getting an RV streaming from it and
drawing a penis on the map or something
that sounds
what is this
this is not our setup by the way Chad if
it wasn't if it wasn't abundantly clear
yet we're guests here and if your client
doesn't have it if you're if you're a
smarty pants you might know where we're
guests you may have seen this place
um I love how there's a huge feedback
loop and your response is oh
okay
I'm not an audio guy okay I'm just a guy
hold on everybody hold on wait oh it's
not plugged in
it
self again
why would it not be [ __ ] in
who with the right mind would I put this
in mark it was probably put into a
separate recorder for like a video they
did in here
so what's capturing the sounds is it is
it the is it the camera it's just the
camera is like going into the HDMI
which we couldn't even find where the
cameras were capturing but I guess it's
nice
yeah well that's a good thing I fiddled
around with the mixer so much that
probably was gonna fix it yeah
laughs
I I appreciate that Mark is fixing it
too but I [ __ ] love that like Tyler
was looking at it and I was like I'll
help and then Mark was like oh let me
fix it
I would have found the problem right
away I'm sorry I can't believe you all
right fixed this yet all right this
might fix it in three two
oh I guess they saw what happened to
what person is oh dang it we were live
on three oh yeah Molly they saw you
yeah it sounds fantastic now
that sounds perfect mark
isn't that crazy it is loud fix it in
OBS Mark fix it in OBS fix this post
we'll just fix it in post
yeah oh yeah oh I'm hot I'm hot compared
to Wade
talk talk talk test test yeah it's
compressed Mark that should be fine okay
you might have to change the volume on
your end chat because we need to re-mute
the fourth microphone is that still good
microphone is muted on the switchboard
so it should be it's fine it's fine
excellent I don't think it is muted but
I think it's fine
all right all right uh maybe let's just
start over let's start over guys we're
going to start over play the intro again
redo this play the intro run the intro
Tyler oh what a show it has been
reactions
oh yeah Mark is the intro oh hey okay
welcome everybody to the inaugural
stream if you made it through the
previous section you are now eligible
for the giveaway
um congratulations thank you so much you
you didn't abandon us in our time of
needs we won't remember this uh for
everyone that disgraced themselves by
abandoning us while we were struggling
through those of you who persevered you
actually do
get to be a part of this experience and
we are giving away what are we giving
away uh a mom the new car and cut away
cut to Wade cut to Wade cut the cut the
weight now cut away oh it did I think
Tyler's still trying to fix the auto I
think I might be peeking in the board oh
all right board the board won't be
peaked wait what are we giving away a
mom's car check the m6 that's what I
just plugged in uh maybe an M6 guys
listen uh stick around
guys stick around uh we're having some
technical difficulties still
um if you don't abandon us in our time
of need you will be eligible for the
giveaway but only those who don't
abandon us in our time of need will be
eligible for the giveaway
um we want to thank you so much for
being
here uh and thank you for all of your
good amounts of time and support uh
loving all these new members on Mark's
specifically YouTube paid mine
and you are just about a beautiful right
and I hope that you will
I have a solution to this
problem
all right did you fix it
okay as if it looks a lot better than it
was but if it it
yeah how's it sounds fine
let me hear it
it's still on
can we do it okay all right yeah we did
it what a bit what a bit you're peeking
oh is he peeking me or Bob am I peeking
yeah he's peeking all right peeking
Bob talk
this is how I normally
uh check sibilance sibilance check
three six yeah uh we have not been
together doing a stream like this in a
an extremely long time just dream like
this I can't even imagine when was the
last time I'm remembering at the uh this
isn't doesn't exist so I guess it's not
Secret The one shirt Warehouse yeah
remember when we did that yeah yeah yeah
is that the last time we did like a that
wasn't even that that was my office that
I had oh was it yeah oh that was my
specific old office that I used to have
wasn't it at Wade's house the Christmas
with the water bottle right that
everyone that Tyler almost died during
yeah that was pre-27 that was 2016 2015.
it's like yeah holy oh so that was
that was before the last tour but that
was the last time I think we did like a
stream yeah so for those of you who are
OG members of uh my
community
my my
my my community
you okay Tyler you okay
what else are you doing he's got one
other up on the third monitor there yeah
why are you looking at porn porn
that was just Cindy cindigo's uh that
made me think of cynical holy [ __ ] no
Corridor wow because I remember that
office was because yeah that's when we
were doing more with synagogue that's
when they first came to La that was the
weirdest Freudian slip I've ever and
that's not even a Freudian I've never
seen something on Corridor in the same
room at the same time they could be the
same
not well
no I don't think that's a thing anyway
uh you're telling me corridors looking
up porn
why not what I was trying to say words
words camera is that that new AI anime
titty generator yeah is that the anime
titty generator
put on your webcam put on your webcam
you have a camera he doesn't have a mic
over there he has a camera over there
it's tylar
oh [ __ ]
all right so anyway uh what would we
turn we were trying to say something oh
yeah we have not been together in a very
long time which is why two years we are
celebrating this moment together it is a
Monumental occasion we are going to be
live streaming for a very long time I
have hit news articles from our lead
reporter Pam in the field Pam
show Pam
pam pam
she's in the field is that the fields
it's a very desolate field with no audio
equipment or cameras of any kind Phil is
cutting out a little bit cutting out a
lot uh but we do have uh breaking news
from uh the field look at the audio clip
Mark boners
no no the funny one
turned around no no it's the uh and uh
look if you see the market cap right
man if you guys don't know what these
references are I'm so sorry but you have
to cut you have to stick through it for
it to be eligible for the giveaway you
must stay here and be in here to be
eligible for the grand giveaway at the
end of this segment and we have multiple
giveaways throughout the Stream
we laughing at we do yeah and they're
all planned and exist already don't
worry about it yeah what they're all I
want that Mom so bad
Oh you mean iPod Touches they're old
they're like engraved with markiplier
from 2016. I've got this pocket lint I
just discovered this is a used Oculus
water bottle give that away that does
not work as a headset look these guys
are goofing but I actually have it right
here in my backpack the thing of which
that could be the most one of the
giveaways Frick is it hold on I don't
even know what it is still all right
hold on none of us know what it is
that's an off camera well how much is in
your bag what are you doing in there the
Hunger Games
distractible you'll never know you'll
never know until you gotta stick around
if you want to know what that is we
should put it on a spinning pedestal
what are you doing Tyler
pepper still don't touch it you'd reveal
more than the the you gotta tease him
yeah
I have it I clearly have a handle on
this why aren't you doing your your job
you yeah I'm looking at the right
direction
and you you son of a [ __ ] what do you
think I got weighted racing in person in
Marcus uh you oh you shut up down there
oh I'll hurt you we're next to each
other
[Music]
you're okay make her make our fingers
meet in the middle oh thingy me
oh wow any if you guys Photoshop take a
screenshot of this everyone at home and
then put yourself in the top no and now
finally don't show this cycle the entire
opportunity that I was giving people at
home to be a part of this is now gone
there now if you take a screenshot of
this and put your finger in the top left
corner you too can be a part of
distractible history
with us the cousin that's distracted
anyway the tips
of the deep
what is that the giveaway
I thought I was reading the cover no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no way no way less guesses I want to
see guesses yeah what do you think what
is it the Holy Bible wow okay someone
already guessed the thing I wish it
actually was what the Bible book by you
called the lore
the lore the Lord okay uh I know this is
supposed to be about distractible but
you guys have to persevere through this
because uh I'm using this as a platform
to get all of my obligations of things
that I was supposed to talk about out of
the way that are not relevant to this
moment I am using you I'm using all of
you it's worth it as long as they go
follow distractible oh don't show me on
my glasses up but you look so easy
go go follow go [ __ ] go follow
distractible on wherever you there you
go go follow distractible on Spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts you
should listen to podcasts on Spotify
because it's it's
you
are glasses where are they you know what
are you not reading today
I don't wear glasses because I got eye
surgery I take Saturday
Fridays off Friday Saturdays Friday
anyway we're missing the point uh the
the pre-sale for my mom's documentary
Markiplier from North Korea you know
my mom the documentary about my mom
we're missing the point of all three of
us coming together
is up on moment house and I don't have
the link in front of me it exists it's
there it's a scavenger hunt you have to
find it but remember if you leave this
stream for any moment you will not be
eligible for the giveaway
and we do have special software
monitoring that
[Laughter]
loud typing for the edge of the room I
don't know I don't think you can hear it
chat but whatever Tyler types it's very
distracting the entire room is just the
echo of the keyboard
um but yeah so it is kind of a nice
experience to be here like I will talk
more about that and I'll have the actual
link I I know right now Evan is just
like he's having an aneurysm right now
look we will talk more about Mark's mom
just give us more about all of these
wonderful things but we are it is kind
of special I'm very grateful for you
guys coming into town for this you guys
did travel to get here and this is like
a very special moment because we never
expected uh that the dumb idea we had on
the roof of that that story about
Australia is actually very true yep we
had an idea that we were going to just
have an excuse to get together because
we missed hanging out with each other
even at that point it had been a while
since we did like a communal stream or
something like that
um and so we just decided that like hey
why don't every Tuesday or so we pick
today I don't even know if we picked the
day that boy we're just like we're gonna
get in and do a live stream together and
that's what started the three peens
podcast it was not a podcast as we
called it that we didn't even know what
a real podcast is we still don't to this
day
um but then you guys stuck around and
then some people came along and was like
why don't you do this officially and
then we beat the [ __ ] out of Joe Rogan
for at least 24 hours a day
we destroyed Joe Rogan didn't see it
coming he was crying at home he was so
sad yeah couldn't even record his
podcast he was so distractible that day
yeah he was distracted by us the
tractors
well if the followers are called the
distracted I guess we are called the
distractors the distracted that's what
they're called they can if you become a
member of the YouTube channel you're one
of the distracted yeah so ominous it
does well it sounds like a cult because
it is yeah pretty much but but I do want
to say like in a little over a year now
maybe like a year and almost a year and
a half now we started in May midday we
still have not been doing it at May 17th
I remember the trailer
I'm trying
coming May 17th yeah we we basically uh
we haven't been doing it as long as
we've been doing the live streams which
is crazy to think about we did those for
almost two whole years before we did the
podcast yeah
um but in that time like it's been just
like a really really nice experience to
be able to have people in the subreddit
like is just like grown and funnier
every day like like that's the one thing
about you guys out there is just like
you're very funny don't let go to your
head um but you are sometimes you
sometimes make us laugh occasionally on
occasion every once in a while
um but it's just cool to see people
rally around the idea and it's cool to
still see people like oh never ever ever
listen to it I'll never listen never you
can't make me not a podcast oh God and
we're like okay and they were like if it
doesn't have video we'll never do oh we
like seeing made like this customer you
promoted this you're advertising your
podcast I don't listen to things that
are told to me that exist there you
don't know I'd like you three people who
even are not
could you do more of the end of the post
is always also oh and play raft
or when will there be more Drunk
Minecraft I love when you three get
together and do stuff can you do
something other than that podcast I love
you guys I've been watching you since
2007 you're my favorite YouTubers
especially the three of you together why
did you do this why did you do
God you put it behind up like a free pay
wall oh you played Minecraft together
doing essentially this for years and you
never even built a house in Minecraft
unless you watched that one episode but
why are you doing this clearly it was
about the gameplay that's the truth that
is the truth and the Butter's voice
which I can but won't do anymore exactly
totally possible but I'm just choosing
not to yes absolutely
um but all that out of the way uh you
guys got anything to say before we get
into the main meat of the matter here
not a damn thing mm-hmm I don't know
just follow it I feel like we see a lot
of feedback of people who are like oh I
don't listen to podcasts I refuse to use
Spotify okay I don't have apple okay
this is on like all of the podcast
platforms that have any uh audience
whatsoever there's a whole ton there's
like Stitcher Google podcast is pretty
good uh and free all of these things are
free to use there's I don't even know
the names of them there's like a dozen
or more podcast platforms that this is
available on for free where you may or
may not even need an account just like
listen to it we're sorry it's not been
on YouTube okay I know you're used to
that it's free it's a hundred percent
free you know one of the coolest
interactions I had I had to take the
dogs in for like a vet appointment after
uh well dogs are great thanks for it
because they're wood
I'm not breaking Ginger's back again you
did this yeah guys you are the leading
cause of back injuries and dogs dogs
back injury but I was at the vet not
related to the back injury and uh after
everything was done I was getting ready
to leave the lady at the desk was like
by the way I love your podcast and there
was another guy in there who brought it
his dog he was like oh you have a
podcast and like before I could say
anything the lady behind like the
counter was like raving about how good
our podcast was how much she enjoyed it
and stuff and it was just like really
awesome to hear and I was like I guess
she likes it I think it's stupid but if
you like it great and then she's like
yeah you should listen to he's like I'll
listen to it right now and he was like
they went to his phone to download it
and just like hearing someone give like
a real not us like endorsement of it was
like really just uplifting to here it
was nice to hear someone's really loving
the podcast it is very nice so download
it it always makes me cringe when it
comes up too but I've heard from like
family members and people who I know who
are just like friends outside of YouTube
like friends and family from regular
life like oh I listened to that whatever
episode and I'm like
and they have always been like oh I
listened to it oh it's great it was
hilarious the dick jokes are okay but
it's very funny
but also I had a similar experience to
you with the vet Wade but we are at a
restaurant and uh Manny like got up and
was getting and was sort of walking away
and as I was about to leave the waitress
grabbed my elbow and really creepily
into my ear was like
and I was like hmm
I don't have one of those
well at least you have one subscriber so
if you find any only fans with a guy
that looks like me or three guys that
look like us doing only fan stuff it
could be mine
we look the same yeah we sound look the
same how much would people pay if I
actually had an only fans all of the
money with like actual nudes with full
odd nudes people would go bankrupt to
get whatever the highest tier vaccine is
that the giveaway
since it was technically my idea do I
get a cut no guaranteed
it how much does
is that what you're looking at over
there is that whoa why wasn't there just
uh something that happened this past
week where somebody hacked amaranth's
only fans and there was like 900 Grand
sitting on her account because she's
exceeds the maximum withdrawal every
month or whatever
yeah so I heard something I apologize
remind me who this is again this is like
a very what are the top like ASMR hot
tub streamer I just learned this
recently because it came up in the
subreddit she's like huge she hasn't
only fans she does twitch I'm Googling
this not to look up the only
assume that I know so many more people
on the internet than I actually know if
people came up to me and asked me like
oh man are you friends with so and so I
wouldn't know who you were talking about
because I don't pay attention even you
guys do that I think I I think I know
there was I forget it was this morning I
guess
on the way here you guys were talking oh
yeah of course of course you guys were
talking about something that happened at
breakfast and you were just tossing out
names you're like oh yeah they're
related to potato snacks and and like uh
spicy spicy light and I was like who the
[ __ ] are they potato snacks spicy like I
don't remember the names because they
mean nothing to me yeah my favorite
YouTubers
whenever I get together with other
YouTubers who are like really in the OR
streamers who are in the community there
I was like oh have you seen Dick
lightning did you see his strength like
no man I don't know we just I like and
and this isn't a disparaging way like
we're obviously uh above and better than
this yeah obviously in every single way
we're above and better than them but we
look down at them with Grace uh but
whoever they are like we started at
really low really low levels of dick
sucking level what what
would
too late
too late
[Music]
okay anyway this is it is one of those
things where I know we're getting older
and we really got to talk about that at
some point yeah
you know it's like it's like uh as as I
am constantly pursuing all these crazy
insane projects like I was telling them
earlier the past four days straight I've
been editing a TV show uh and uh it's
I'm really excited about it because I
finally got to dig my hands into it it's
for a secret project that I can't tell
anybody I'll tell you at the end of the
stream if you stick around
yeah
anyway so I've been working very hard on
that and it's like that's the [ __ ] that
I love that is what I love I love like
the actual process of creation I love
actually working on it I love staying up
late I love pulling all-nighters I love
when I care so much about a product or a
project that I can't think about
anything else it's a byproduct of like
who I am and the way that I work but
it's just like I love that
um and that's why I always say that I've
always said this I'm so excited about
the people that are going to be the next
generation of creators because I can't
wait to see what people are gonna make I
love seeing what people are gonna make I
we're literally in a studio of people
that I greatly respect but they make so
much that I was an intern here have you
guys not seen the internship that I did
with Corridor uh it's it's on their
website that's behind their paywall but
they got a free trial so go check it out
um but it's just like I really love just
I the the joy of creation you know
you know you know I feel it differently
all right fine it was making a reference
but I and I don't what reference is that
you know the the joy of creation yeah oh
yeah that you know yeah you know Bim
trimmer
is that you don't even know that
reference God they don't even know that
reference
why do so few people not know I'm not
Bim trimmer himself but me going you
know him trimmer did Ethan make that or
something no God explain it
okay cut back to me cut back to me cut
back to me hi I'm here too
I've got a big thing I'm
too late
anyway just like it's a stupid thing
because like I remember to Catherine
specifically Catherine uh it was like I
think we should do I think we should
have Bim trimmer in there and Catherine
what who's been trimmer and I went you
know
Bim trimmer and then I said nothing else
remember when he said that to Catherine
that time oh yeah when we were all there
yeah when you were there just whatever
guys I'm done
no it's really funny because Amy just
was sitting there staring at Mark like
Bim trimmer you got you know Bim
well I was gonna agree with your
previous point but now I feel like I
don't even know what my point was
listening
oh yeah I like the joy of live creation
I'm not a good writer and I don't have
the vision of like crafting a visual
whatever but the interactions that we
have especially if Jack is involved but
just the three of us live in person and
even like we've captured it online but
it's better in person also because the
tour the tour was terrifying for me and
I feel like I had some really bad shows
just because I got like stage fright but
even still it's a very fond memory I
wish we could do more in person stuff
it's quite it's quite the experience the
joy of the the Bim trimmer of creation
if you will
wow yes the bimetration the tremation
cremation
don't don't look at me
you're still on there damn it uh yeah uh
but another reason why we kind of did
this podcast is because we have a habit
I did have a point I'm finally back
around to the point is that we or at
least I have this thing where I like to
I like to
oh oh what I don't know what happened I
guess the hand motion is very funny the
uh the I I like to
[Laughter]
why is it God how unprofessional are we
that we're
amused pipe multicam wow this is awkward
we don't get to do that
[Applause]
why I don't know I'm hungry
don't look at me so anyway so it's like
we're what's your point mark
is it Ben's trimmer we kind of had this
thing or at least that was the thing
where I like just uh showing that you
don't have to be professional I don't
know intruding into other people's
sacred zones where they're just like oh
they have the other walled Gardens and
it's like you know especially with like
podcast based words it's just a bunch of
traditional like actors and things like
that and what it's not it's it's just
like literally like late night TV with
all the interviews over and over again
where you have a guest in there and it's
fine it's not like we'd ever be a
post-guess but it's kind of was like one
of the things where like we just want to
do something where we three because we
knew it worked on Twitch we streamed on
Twitch for two years straight and people
[ __ ] loved it we like people showed
up because we just were having a good
time and people love it it's been the
Mantra of my channel you make good stuff
people will enjoy it and that's been the
driving principle of everything but now
we're in the podcasting world and let me
tell you us having success in the
podcasting world does not make people
happy yeah does not make everyone happy
more than ever I'm sure I have less of a
picture than you do because I know you
you talk you talk more to like the
business side people than I get to I
think but I can tell that we
we have showed up in the podcast space
and if we had pitched this idea even if
we had a couple episodes if we had
pitched this before it was a thing and
before we knew what was going to go yeah
and we did Pitch it to some people and
talk about everybody left it out of the
room like everybody was like well that's
not a podcast
that and like yeah it's different and I
don't think it's different than all
podcasts because there are some
definitely some podcasts that are
funnier than ours is that I listen to
and are like Inspirations for me when
I'm thinking about like what ideas
should we do how should we construct an
episode but
yeah I would imagine I totally believe
you because the response we got
initially was like
okay good luck
good luck guys have fun there was this
one uh I I talked to Tyler about this a
while ago I won't name names I really
want name names and that's Tyler he's
right there turn on your camera Tyler we
won't name your name Tyler
that's not your oh hey look at that
all right so I was talking to Tyler we
have go my favorite sports team which is
another podcast I do with Tyler by the
way I also do that one once
it's the best episode there is of it
numbers don't don't look at me
all right you're not looking just turn
your camera off
no I want them to want to see I hate
that that's true I really do there's a
whole nother podcast where it's me and
Tyler and the one episode where Wade is
on replacing Mark as a tester is because
I was sick with covid and they're really
questioning Mark's Place on that podcast
is literally the most popular episode
and I kind of take that personally I
kind of take it a little personally guys
I feel I feel like cumulatively if you
look at all the episode numbers that we
have forego and you add them up I'm
crushing you in terms of total I can't
believe that out of your 30 episodes 29
of them out number one you gotta look at
success per capita that's the way you
get the truth of it
weight only has one cap did uh what's a
capita I don't know how many is per
tapped by my success I have a point to
make I'll get two okay if we just ignore
the these other ideas yeah it's Bim
trimmer
why'd you let us talk then Mark geez
why do I permit you to talk we are here
to talk about Mark's mom and we're
giving away the
what was your point mark I have a point
is uh I mean again I'm not gonna name
names but I remember early on in
distractible
uh my manager Ben who is great Ben
hi Ben if you're watching uh
he was sending out emails to be like
okay let's see if you can get on other
podcast to promote
um distractible like that'd be it's a
natural fit and there was someone
who been reached out to who responded
basically and said Markiplier that
YouTuber
yeah right and literally that was the
response that you type in the email and
I
the episode that came up Thursday I
talked about them and I took that very
much to heart because if you know me I
operate not entirely on [ __ ] you energy
but I really really really love proving
people wrong like [ __ ] their dreams [ __ ]
their nightmares you're gonna beat them
no that's too late
[Laughter]
all right right in the camera Wade right
up there into the camera that's too late
now you cut away no now you do it oh
which part [ __ ] your dreams [ __ ] your
nightmares I'm gonna beat you yeah then
so that I still see that little
asshole's face I see it I'm gonna crush
his skull on my hand that's a high
school man you gotta let that one go
that's a little you can find something
he's older now too
we're getting older him too yeah well
then it's not really a child's head I
don't know what you think it's gonna be
this big
he had a small head for his body yeah he
had no brain couldn't come up with a
good stuff shrunken head yeah it's like
one of those Beetlejuice [ __ ] up
I gotta watch the mic as I go around you
all right cool good anyway so uh ever
since then I've been I've been very much
just like yeah I don't usually try to
compete in things I don't try to compete
on YouTube I don't really care about
many metrics of success until someone
says other says that I can't and then I
care very much
we can't get distractible to pass Joe
Rogan again
by who it matters who and in what
context that's the same person yeah the
same one I was texting with them and
they were like
out of nowhere people just like to like
send random insults from like a b c d
accounts where they've got the egg
picture and like the only tweet they had
in their entire account was at me saying
hey your podcast will never touch Joe
Rogan's again like out of nowhere and it
was the only tweet they had they made
that account to send that and then they
were done oh that's fair that's fair
that's understandable
or is it Anyway there's a link in the
description if you guys haven't checked
out distractible yet or even if you have
why don't you go listen to your favorite
episode why don't everyone in the
comments in the side here or down below
why don't you tell other people what
your favorite episode is there's been
some bangers lately and we have been
exceptionally funny and clever I heard
from the subreddit that the naked
episode was quite a favorite amongst
people which I was both shocked and
delighted by
the best part about that episode was you
locking Us in where we were like we had
to pick a ranking and then we just had
to stick with it throughout the whole
thing
really worked out it totally worked out
it really did yeah so uh why don't you
go check that out because um we do have
an upcoming thing that we want to
we have an opportunity coming up soon
we're not going to talk about what it is
but we have an opportunity to come soon
and it's kind of one of those things
where it's that competitive nature in me
wants to win I don't usually care much
about things accolades what not
even though space should have won an
Emmy
yeah I was in that so I agree it has an
interactive category and they didn't
even put it in there yeah I can't
imagine what else I don't know what was
in that category but what else came out
in the past year that is even close to
that I don't know see these are the kind
of things that I want to break into
these are why is because number one I
firmly believe that YouTube YouTubers as
creators and internet content creators
in general are more creative than anyone
ever gives them credit for the amount of
work that people put in and the
individual skills that you build in
terms of being able to do individual
creativity is so underestimated by the
Greater Community in terms of like
Hollywood and traditional Media stuff
like that they have no idea and I
definitely want to be one of the people
that proves all of them wrong even if I
have to grab them by their scrawny
little necks nothing I say you're such a
scrotums
scrotums they got the littlest
itty-bitties
punching bags I'll show you and so like
that that really is one of those things
where I I love making videos and I love
doing this podcast with you guys and I
love hanging out and I love the
opportunity to be here but also God I
really want everyone watching us right
now to understand just how much I want
to win
and every one of them that downloads or
listens to distractible somewhere helps
us to do that yeah
and go he's listening to go to I'm on
that I have the best episode oh sure now
you promo it now that you're now that
you have an episode on it yeah duh yeah
I got invited to that and I turned it
down because I was too thank God
I was busy it was two bees too important
for it I understand you don't know
Sports anyway so it's all right no I
hate Sports you don't get it like I Get
It Go sharks I was great at tonsil
hockey
did you whip your dick out or not on the
podcast
you have to listen to it to find out all
right I was told how do you tell with
audio only if he whipped oh you know you
know when he did was that have like a
specific whoosh aerodynamics of your
shirt it's like a fingerprint all of our
dicks have their own unique it sounds
like an automatically inflating raft
that you throw out of an airplane
yeah I love that future you're going to
work in your high security this guy
scraper and all the all the women are in
one line doing whatever the equivalent
would be and all the dudes have one line
where they're just like unzip whoosh it
over the sensor no you whoosh you swing
it over and it's all and they're like
yeah well you have a whoosh I have a
flop
we each have our own fingers are you
saying that the future is Dick print
identification I mean wouldn't the
future be male-centric isn't that the
way things go
I mean
they do call it the Patriots talk about
the hard-hitting issues on this podcast
and I want to talk no uh because women
are going to build spaceships and leave
us here to die on this planet they
deserve it honestly we they they deserve
that and we deserve that we go to
Jupiter to get more stupider they go to
Venus to get the good penis or something
right
well in fact the Russia is actually
launched a well a well-known Gigolo
to Venus in the early uh 70s and he's
actually there in a cryostasis pod
waiting for the witch
they're trying to show people the
quality that we have the quality oh it's
not the quality it's it's a funny
podcast okay it's supposed to be funny
this part's allowed to be funny
penis is funny dude it's always funny it
never gets old it's it's like we've got
so many levels of irony that you
wouldn't understand how funny it really
is unless you've been listening for very
long oh my God a penis is like a little
mouse don't a potato sack race
what
that's when swooshing around it's like a
little mouse head and like the sacks
like a potato sack that's where it's
like trying to run around what are you
talking about nothing go ahead I think
he's talking about what he thinks
penises look like why are we talking
about that this is supposed to be
profound moment where it's like we're
channeling our [ __ ] you energy into
beating everyone because we actually
care I always wanted a [ __ ] energy
not [ __ ] I don't have [ __ ] you energy
I don't know if you've noticed from the
several times we've talked about that
General topic but I only have one story
that even comes close to [ __ ] you energy
I just see the comment eight inches
yes this is live by the way we are
looking at you we just never he's not
saying anything
yeah why don't you guys be funnier than
we might acknowledge your comments yeah
slow Mo's only have 15 seconds you got
all this time in the world to think up a
clever comment for us to see you know
what I can only see comments from people
who've already followed the podcast on
multiple platforms so it's mostly blank
to me you have follow Vision yeah that's
what what do you think I wear glasses
for uh filters out all the people who
don't follow my content online oh I see
wow impressive no mock my technology I'm
not this is my version I have hologram
don't look at me
don't don't look at me oh my goodness
all right where's your Monumental
personal feeling point mark I made it
already oh it was great I literally
finished it a while ago [ __ ] those
idiots we're gonna win at podcast yeah
we're gonna win it I mean honestly right
with your help that's my camera yes yes
your help with your help
I think it'd be more dramatic if it
wasn't perfectly like the tip of your
nose yeah anyway Link in the description
for that so that's the that's the
initial volley of promotional blasting
that we will do uh we are done with that
for now because we are going into the
hard-hitting news
and it's our fault oh wait what's your
what I killed K-pop in that episode
remember I don't know in fact from the
Abate debate episode Wade actually
really hates K-pop so murder aim it all
at him he hates it it will never
financially recover from me but uh
breaking news from Mark
Pam
you got panel on the horn
Tyler you're supposed to be calling me
up this whole time are you not setting
up the remote right now you got the
remote you got the zoom producer Tyler
over there it's not even all right I
think well she's emailed us a story that
Mark will
have had yeah all right so we're into
the breaking news segment we'll give you
a little taste of the glory that is
the distractible podcast this uh hard
dating reporting is
from Pam's Research into the BBC
thank you BBC News Pam thank you BBC
News Pam this is uh uh uh uh the story
about a lawyer which I think both of you
can relate to very much so we both have
heard of them lawyers quote I have
foolishly shot myself Winston Clement
Valen dingham classic lawyer line
sinking into a chair in his hotel room
in a mixture of pain and mortification
the Calamity which ended the former
congressman's days happened in the town
of Lebanon Warren County Ohio I know
where Lebanon is I can relate to lawyers
in Ohio
this is a there's a story for everyone
to get a little piece of what else what
a ding dang donger all right halfway
through the case he thought would be the
greatest of his life
at stake was a man's life
the Christmas Eve before a Rough and
Ready character called Thomas Myers had
been playing cards in a private room
above a bar in nearby Hamilton when five
thugs burst in and a huge brawl broke up
that's forward what five I didn't want
to get two in it like his five
as Myers Rose scrabbling to draw his
pistol from his pocket a muffled shot
was heard he pulled out the gun fired
off a couple Wayward rounds then slumped
back down
I hope that's not the thing I say when I
kill myself accidentally
I'm trying to get my gun out of my
pocket and pop and I'm like ah I have
foolishly shot myself in the foot
like man damn
so much worse with that line dude yeah
what a way to go in the wild confusion
of the moment as gamblers fled in all
directions it wasn't clear what was
happening but when the witness later
recounted their tails one name came up
again and again Myers
Dingle Hammer hey I could see it the
reflection of your camera my hair is a
Noir
they're 10 Noir how is that spelled
oh it's not with the french letters wow
b-e-t-e Noir
Myers
beaten hour what what is this
beat now or Ben Tremors Nemesis
Bim trimmer Thomas mcgahen
no one could say for sure that he was
armed that night but he was certainly
one of the gang of gate Crashers
everyone knew there was bad blood
between the two the judge juries who
gathered at Hamilton's Street Corner
Shop counters and saloon Bars were
satisfied they had the Killer
and so it came to trial and one evening
after the prosecution had closed their
arguments Mr Valen dingham took a piece
of Muslim from his hotel headed out for
open land and conducted his own CSI Ohio
experiment to establish the levels of
residue left by a shot fired at Point
Blank Range so the confusion right
I can that red is behind you
he was just like getting down behind
he doesn't even notice listen to
distractible [ __ ] you okay so they
should have the killer so this is where
the confusion is Gang breaks in
five men run in a room one man's dead
the person who was in the room prior
so they're like of course he was shot
dead he was murdered uh but this lawyer
was trying to piece together what
happened
so when he was done three live rounds
remained in the chamber of his pistol
this as we shall see was unfortunate
because back at the Lebanon House Hotel
he was handed a parcel inside was
Meyer's gun unloaded and ready to be
examined valentingham went in to his
room laid on both pistols side by side
still flush with the success of his test
the lawyer began explaining to visitors
that Myers had actually shot himself
none of the gunmen who entered to kill
that man that day shot him he declared
that the man had inadvertently shot
himself
like this bang literally you are 100
correct as to how this story continues
did he do it because of [ __ ] you energy
was like the Assassins are here they
each want to take credit they're not
gonna get me I'm gonna get me
this is the lawyer uh oh you're talking
about the guy yeah yeah uh I don't think
it was intentional he's like haha you're
yeah you're not firing me I'm firing I
quit oh get me first yeah I don't think
that was the case here so I just want to
highlight a couple facts about this
because yes this is not how things will
be handled uh modernly the gun
was shipped to the lawyer at his hotel
room
a piece of peace evidence which in
modern times there has to be an insanely
strict chain of custody proving who I
was certified mail it was like he had
control of it and you know not allowing
people to screw around with it also he's
at his hotel for this right yeah is
there any explanation or context that
explains why there's visitors
lawyers at his hotel and there's just
people like
he brought them to demonstrate oh okay
his clients innocent his client being
one of the five men who broke in and was
accused of shooting isn't that what he
was supposed to do in court I feel like
demonstrating it to this picture he
invited the jury in his hotel room he
had a jacuzzi in his room
[Music]
real slippery in this town oh my God I
guess a murder happened in town and that
was basically the only thing that had
happened that week so everyone was into
it but like I just I get that like
everyone at the time was like ooh a
murderer but people are just like
waiting like God I hope that lawyer
invites us over so he could show us his
arguments yeah I know right I mean
that's the most fun thing we could do
yeah so remember this lawyer is like he
was testing in the field like to see if
his theory was correct that like there
was a way that he could pull the gun and
accidentally shoot yourself and he was
doing it like with an unloaded gun
uh unfortunately
the lawyer began explaining to a visitor
that Myers had actually shot himself
then had a sudden brain wave he'd stage
his own demonstration he grabbed a
pistol put it in his pocket drew it
slowly turned the muzzle on himself
and then pulled the trigger
so I'm gonna do this for you real slow
pay attention uh we also have a loaded
gun this is how it happened oh God
keep watching are you watching are you
watching this is how it happened I like
the idea that he's explaining it to he's
like he had he had his sidearm talked
thusly in his pocket and as a simple man
he scrambled to reach his sidearm when
the Assassins entered the room something
like this problems
slowly he finally draws the weapon and
in his Panic aims it as his own self and
prematurely blah
well I think maybe he had it like in
like a slit on his side and he undid the
sling he's like hey guys I got these
things bro
no no you're forgetting five men that
approached him from all angles he had to
keep his eye on all of them
so he went oh
[Applause]
shot himself like this and then he you
know what he should have done for safety
he should have been like I have a theory
about how he struggled to draw his
weapon and it was I would love to see
how all of you think he may have shot
himself so I prepared five loaded
pistols if you grab one that's a pistol
it's definitely empty wink one of these
is
all of them the winner of our giveaway
gets the unloaded pistol
Jim Smith Val Landing him valending who
wants to play Valentina roulette
so uh he turned the muzzle on himself
and pulled the trigger bang quote the
unfortunate Advocate had demonstrated
the reasonableness of his theory
but at the cost of his life
began to court and the defense is just
sitting at his table like
he's most he's supposed yeah right is
this happening or what all the witnesses
just come in and all sit down in the one
chair for the defense lawyer like look
he died but we see we see we can we show
you do you have a do you have a loaded
gun because we could demonstrate this
man's innocence yeah
we need to see it more than once you
guys are unbelievers are happening
that's just a voice
genius actually he brought five
witnesses in so it was perfectly
recreating the moment and we didn't know
why we needed to burst through the door
they all five have to demonstrate at
once then they fall over again exactly
it's like it's like oh man isn't there
uh there's a [ __ ] SNL sketch or
something like that like whoa you took
the gun then they Point him
what'd you say no no no no oh yeah yes
no yes that's why they all keep shooting
each other but it doesn't have any
dialogue like you're talking about it's
not like that no anyway so the dark
force was still not played out quote
hardly was he in his grave before
another man killed himself while trying
precisely in the same way to demonstrate
how Mr Valance this case is still
ongoing to this day
literally it's what you were describing
before where in look not in the
courtroom specifically but someone else
like yes the craziest thing you don't
believe it I'll show you he pulled out
his guns Lauren
well actually both his Laura and the guy
who killed himself I got two guns
nowador has some guns maybe we should
demonstrate live on stream how this went
what could possibly go wrong in a
demonstration oh my God one of the first
guy was demonstrating too I I know that
people get pretty Cavalier when they
like own guns too but
isn't like the one of the first couple
rules of gun safety when you pick up a
gun check it and make sure the slide is
clear or the chambers
this is 1800s give it heck yeah kids
used to play with loaded guns just
because it was something to do
yeah so in the end the person the
defendant actually was acquitted
but who did it but three people had to
die demonstrating his defense only to be
shot himself a few years later by
himself by the same gun no one knows
you know what it is it's a Haunted Gun
yeah the gun is just out to get everyone
you didn't want that guy who got off on
the murder charge telling his secrets to
the world yeah where's the gun now I
don't know he was he was murdered
apparently maybe but the quote the end
quote is the hamiltonians because it's
too he wanted to live in Hamilton France
Ohio okay
uh threatened to take his life if he
attempted to make his home in that City
said Ohio's splendidly named Tiffin
Tribune and they evidently don't like to
be caught in a lie about a small matter
of that kind
hmm so they killed him so is anyone
alive in that town are they all
mysteriously dive gunshot seriously and
someone did say it was it was a TomSka
sketch it was like the the title of is
like what happened I think it was there
is one where it's like time to
demonstrate what happened in the scene I
imagine like them drawing straws like
who's gonna demonstrate what happened
please no please no please no oh thank
God
so that someone inherited that gun and
they're just like at a shooting range or
something and they're doing they're
totally normal they're like holding it
and firing it safely and one time right
as they're about to fire the tip of the
gun becomes a face and peeks around at
them and it's like boom
the bullet comes out of his mouth wow
they're gonna shoot you why is that
that's just the voice of that case I
love that this is just a voice in your
repertoire now I don't it started on the
podcast or maybe it started on streams
but it's just recently yeah I just like
it it's fun yeah it's pretty fun
hey was it no it came up because I was
doing the mocking voice but it's not
trying to emulate it
anyway we're here to help you guys be
convinced of the worthiness of
distractible for your time are you
convinced yet there's literally what we
just did is not a segment on the podcast
no this is live
therefore it wouldn't be so I don't know
why that was a sample that we thought
would convince you that distractible is
worth your time but it is trust me and
if that's not then the Glorious giveaway
that could oh the giveaway
[Applause]
you're moving it too much I can't read
it
okay keep going stop teasing me still I
can't read that'll keep him there for a
little bit longer
they all know what it is now that'll
entice them that'll entice them up a
little bit but anyway there's a link in
the description go check it out I'm
looking at the live stats of people that
are actually following through and I'm
being greatly disappointed by the number
of people that are not checking out
distractible at this very moment and if
you're not checking out distractible I'm
gonna hide in your closet and I'm gonna
punch you in the middle of your sleep
and you'll never know that it was me but
you'll have a big bruise one of you
needs to check your cholesterol too how
do you even get those stats I don't know
man they really pull a lot of analytics
about people
bam I don't have those on my end can I
get access to that no
okay
borrow your laptop no later or something
here
what what are you it's like a little
gnome hat I was tracing it I'm chasing
the step don't look at me
anyway so yes uh we are here and we're
going to literally be shouting about
this forever however that's not the only
thing that we're going to be doing today
what are we going to be doing today Wade
yeah Bob
well
mark
Tyler
that's it that's what we're doing
he's not even one word Tyler anymore no
no no no what I would like to do uh
Tyler hey pull up uh pull up one of the
the animations that they people love
cartoons those idiots love I mean they
love that stuff they love that stuff
those uh the sheep that follow us
cartoons for kids we're gonna share you
and make shirts out of your hair all
those cartoons
I don't know what I'm threatening them
with at this point you got it
I could by the sound of the typing that
Echoes throughout the lens I think he
has found something my laptop won't even
make that loud of a noise no matter what
I do
he's scrolling don't worry everybody wow
what you could search for I'm reading
chat and a lot of you are dead wrong
about what the giveaway is by the way
what do they think it is uh
uh some kind of book
oh
could not be more wrong oh my God how
could there be a mom and a car and a
book all three no way all right let's
see if Tyler's got this Tyler's got this
is that actually happening I love this
ad
is this wait wait is that on stream or
is that us watching it on the TV
he's getting there he's getting there
he's getting there not yet
let's all do the same hand mode
goodbye
so it was fine from the game hello
do they see you they see us yeah oh hey
we were doing really funny
exclusively Mark don't worry I'm sure
you'll see it we were about to be funny
all right are we starting it over yeah
started over God we were so funny for a
few moments we were so unbelievably
funny I swear to God podcast so funny
God I swear it was so good uh here we go
from the top yeah foreign
[Laughter]
Bob you're up first okay you're on a
cruise ship ship encounters the storm
the storm rages on and on and till
eventually you and the other passengers
are told you must head to the lifeboats
and Abandon Ship as you line up you
realize some lines have fewer people
some have families some seem to be
younger single people you know that you
are strong and capable
open-ended question hold on a second
yeah okay how about this yeah you see
that the line at the front line are
young PR uh families you know infirm
people not strong like you you don't
think you're going to make it on a
Lifeboat because this particular boat
does not have enough light bolts to fit
all the people on the ship but the
ship's going down in about five minutes
it's going to be completely underwater
what do you do
uh
music
okay easy easy uh easy one
um I find the nearest crew member and I
uh knock them unconscious I steal their
crew top shirt thing and their life
jacket and their hat so I kind of look
like an official crew member
um I hide them somewhere in conspicuous
it's frantic no one will notice anyway
and then I run to the front of the line
and I start helping uh helping people uh
I'm strong I'm virile helping people get
into the lifeboats at some point I look
into the Lifeboat and I oh what no what
I'll come look at it and then I just hop
into the Lifeboat and life mode and then
I'm in the Lifeboat and I'm looking
around like I'm doing stuff I'm helping
people find their seats I'm looking and
I'm like oh your life here let me fix
your life jacket and I just adjust some
straps and eventually the Lifeboat you
know reloads down into the water set
sail and I'm totally fine everything's
good I won't come look at the uh come
look at this all right uh wait you're up
next all right
what would you do so so I go and I light
a fire because this boat's going down
anyway that's a fire gonna do it's a
distraction okay
while the fire is burning I go and I
help a family you know there's not a
very long line this family gets into the
Lifeboat and I start to lower the
Lifeboat with like a I imagine just some
kind of crane system to lower it down
when I pull one of the levers so only
one half of the boat goes the other half
stays up tipping the passengers out pull
the levers back up hop in myself drop
it's real quick so it lands and crushes
the family so they can't say anything
about what happened and then I drive
away while the fire is burning people
and moving more fine everybody don't
notice what I did
[Laughter]
I'm sure that was a faithful Recreation
good job everybody who knew that it was
already set up to automatically mute our
mics and play the other audio without us
having to do anything what a time to be
alive plot twist I couldn't see the
animation it was just our cameras doing
that the whole time
yeah why is Wade's Mike so much louder
because he's eating it yeah he really
like he's also loud Mike and I were loud
and then Wade was way loud yeah
absolutely this is an obs
what he done swatched him
oh
that's good I can't see the chat
is that what my ears look like in real
life Tyler we worked on this for so long
before we got here yeah we gave you so
much uh why do we give you all the
preferences
surprise our fourth member
no audio and I'm like yes they're live
dubbing it are you talking about the
video or you're not hearing them they're
trying to get to you don't let them get
to you they're trying to get to you
the fourth member is Tyler if you guys
didn't know surprise we that was no
longer a secret oh let's do the podcast
from Tyler's perspective for a little
bit can you switch it to your Kim let's
keep it over there let's keep it over
there we're all in here yeah we're all
here oh don't look at my legs though
they're not that pale you can look at
mine
so anyway uh what what the biggest
strategy about that animation is is like
it did it uh that's one of the best
animation made and it it didn't go out
to people's sub feeds
um YouTube situations yeah so uh you'll
notice that one has markedly less views
even though it has plenty of likes
proportionately to the Views and yet
maybe people just don't like
us oh babe
that's a sad thing maybe people just
don't care about us anymore it's weird
intentionally looking at the wrong cat I
don't know right now this camera is not
good this camera's not good what's wrong
with this camera no no no no
there we go this is the emotional care
when we get emotional and serious this
is where we go guys I just think maybe
we've lost our touch you know well you
know what I think it is
we've changed
you remember at the beginning of
distractible we used to have to have
titles oh my God and we and we told
personal stories
and and said numbers of points instead
of pretending like we do points and just
arbitrarily selecting a winner
remember the real first episode of
distractible we lost him that no one
ever got to hear because we did like
31st episodes of Destruction but we
really let him down haven't we slept
I've not slipped we slipped it's
appropriate for you to be this sad are
we even in the top ten anymore no I
don't know oh God no where are we we're
barely top 20 these days hey Siri where
is distractible
oh God
I found this on the web for where is
destructible 15. check it out
distractible 15 is in the past
it was over
well I
all right well let's get back to the
podcast guys we can't keep them waiting
too much longer no one watches this
anyway anymore but I guess hey what's up
guys that was a cool quick commercial
break thank you so much for being
patient and sticking around you guys are
eligible for that giveaway the big prize
is still yet to be won but there are
hundreds upon hundreds upon hundreds of
things yet to be given to you lovely
people out and a huge congratulations to
those of you who've already won
giveaways I got a teaser for the things
I know about yeah you guys can have some
of these whoa [ __ ] got him got him
right guys right fist bump
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah we I I know we haven't really been
putting uh all of our Hood spy into
everything that we do but we're back
baby and we're we're here to earn that
listen and we're putting our balls in
everything we're gonna earn that listen
we're gonna get back into the top ten
we're gonna We're Gonna Knock on Joe
Rogan's back door and we're gonna be
there again in that sweet delicious top
10 of all podcasts of all time because
we deserve it why are we going in Joe
Rogan we do deserve it and you know what
Mark I have an announcement that I think
we can make that people are gonna go
nuts
right right before right before we came
in here we were talking about a thing
and a schedule for the thing and how
it's gonna be maybe a daily or something
like that can we talk about that yeah we
could totally talk oh this is a big
secret it's been a huge project that I
haven't had to work on at all so it's
been really easy for me but will our
editor has spent
weeks probably months or years of his
life five years in the background still
doing everything he does on a weekly
basis to put out the absolute Gem of a
show that we always do plus the ads you
all love hate so much
but on top of all of that he has spent
the last x amount of time
creating animations for all of those
backlogged episodes that didn't get put
on YouTube
because we made the obviously stupid
decision to stop posting full episodes
on YouTube which everyone except for the
three of us said was the worst idea and
should never have happened and was a
travesty well we made will fix it
and starting I don't know
starting soon there you go uh we are
going to be uploading backlog episodes
daily I just can't believe will made us
stop posting that I begin with you know
yeah you know that's right it was him
wasn't it it was all Will's fault that's
why he had to fix it he said you want to
be rich don't you well stop posting on
YouTube and you'll be wealthy out of
your wildest dreams
the less views you get the more money
you make don't forget about Will's
classic cigar he always has it he's an
old he's old Hollywood player he talks
like that every Zoom call we have with
Will which we have all this daily
[Music]
is very good uh and so with that
hopefully you guys will flood back to
the YouTube channel which is surging its
way to 700 000 subscribers
surging are you telling me it's not even
at a million yet
this is why we're below Jones
can we have a sidebar real quick can we
take a commercial break hey can we uh
yeah play the commercial cut the
commercials
or the dick pills one put the commercial
put the commercial okay
why you gotta call it out like that on
the podcast yeah I thought we were
trying to uh like bait them into no no
following because they feel bad bait
K-pop
we're not doing an episode right now
wait got it look we just gotta trick
them we just gotta trick them with happy
smiles that's psychologically that's
what works the best okay or the little
quarter trick where you're like it's all
you'd find your ears but they're not
here right now it's all the internet so
at least yeah I remember okay the plan
six to eight weeks of medium effort and
then we forget about it again and just
put it on there yeah yeah 100 just we
just got to get through this and then we
never have to see each other again okay
well I was yeah okay so I won't I won't
go I won't point out the symphony thing
that clearly a lot of people uh don't
listen every week the moment they come
out you can you do I still get a coupon
for showing up
I mean the lawsuit's still pending so I
mean literally after the Supreme and
everyone okay you two talk about the
rest I'll just be here like I don't know
can we mute him next time we do a
sidewalk
yeah I agree we can't mute people in
real life like we're immunity yes and
well it's just a Discord setting what do
you mean yes
we're not a Discord exactly
that's really confusing I don't know
what you're talking about I know it's
not quite right anyway let's let's get
back to this okay yeah
hey yeah we're back baby
man if we got almost 700 000 subscribers
on the YouTube channel where we are
surging to Victory thanks to you lovely
people out there the YouTube channel uh
youtube.com
distractible podcast
it's two it's both words distractible
podcast did we not get to yeah no we
didn't do the handle yet
s-t-r-e-c-t-i-b-l-e-d-cast unless did
you do it
well what does that have to do with me I
guessed it on your show how did we not
have youtube.com distractible
no idea I don't control this Todd who oh
yeah have you seen that no did you see
basketballs came out on YouTube so you
could pick you could pick you could pick
Chris Todd you could pick [ __ ] his
dreams [ __ ] his nightmares we're gonna
steal from him guys
look for so little
I want a lot
but they asked for a little probably I
would give anything to just being the
top 10 I would take it I thought we were
going big smiles big smile
I would take anything to be in the top
this is the push all you got to do is
listen get your parents to listen get
your siblings to listen your dog put it
on the baby monitor
put a speaker on top of your car and
drive around with it playing preferably
the funniest episode whichever one you
think that is there's no play it at your
job play it at your funeral
restaurant put podcasts on our podcast
on instead of the music from the
restaurant then people will have such a
good time they'll give you better tips
plus your boss will probably promote you
to shift manager because it was a great
idea that you did that there's so many
ways that this could improve your life I
can't believe you're not taking
advantage of them yeah put a headphone
on your baby bump put a headphone on
each boom put a headphone on each scrote
make everything listen each ball that's
what I meant uh
enough to for the whole crew huh
it
was a good one Breaking News Bulletin
baby baby baby
I turned around this yeah recite it
because you know so well wait and I
turned around there was no one there and
then I don't believe in ghosts I turned
around and when I saw was not meant for
human eyes to turn around and see when
they turn around
this is scary stories of scared turning
oh
I mean that's like that's like 80 right
I really swear that our podcast is
better than this I swear it's it's a
fully fleshed out idea and we have it's
very consisting they can't see me
disagreeing anyway
according to uh Pam's incredible
reporting skills
in the field in the Wilds of Alaska oh
right now Pam is in Anchorage Alaska or
outside the city limits and the Wilds
near Anchorage which is pretty much all
Wilds as soon as you get out of
Anchorage it is wild it's like wild
[Laughter]
you really can't what a word picture you
painted for me I appreciate it I wanted
a yes and with the wild part lead
research in the field and Pam is
discovered while hightailing it away
from a group of hunters that mistooker
for a moose uh discovered that it is
illegal
illegal in Alaska to whisper in another
person's ear if they are hunting moose
in the state of Alaska you know where
that is
I do do you Alaska well we'll compare no
you go first
I know the answer obviously Pam
discovered this by trying to get an
exclusive interview to get the scoop and
just so happened to be an Alaskan
whispered in a hundred ear and did not
know that she inadvertently broke a
sacred law because
concentration
is key
plus it's scary
[Laughter]
that's why I never do it I thought it
was just scared like if you're if you're
a hunter in Alaska and you go out
hunting moose your your whole mindset is
like ah I'm finally alone there's only 3
000 people in my whole city that I live
in but I needed to get away and then if
somebody Whispers In Your Ear while
you're out moose hunting and you think
there's not a soul near you you assume
it's a ghost you shoot your pants and of
course the smell of human [ __ ] scares
away all the mooses in the area if you
get north of Seattle aren't they called
elk
those are different animals and
different names I don't think that's a
location today I think a moose is a
moose and an elk is an elk but I've got
a mouse inside was a mouse but a mouse
outside's a rat no those are different
species as well all right go on no no
wait what other things do you think what
are what are related species tell me
please uh dick in your pants okay a dick
out of your pants lawsuit no actually if
it's in your pants it's magma it's lava
once it comes out God I swear it's
better than this guys I swear the
podcast is so much better all right Mark
what happened to pam pam we don't know
we lost contact with Pam outside a
hundred miles outside of Anchorage I'm
hoping that she can navigate with the
Stars but as you know so far up north
the stars are at that high of a latitude
are actually in a completely different
position well if it's the wrong time of
year isn't it light for like 20 hours a
day yeah yeah and it's currently dark
for like oh well that makes the Stars
okay it does but also
Stars uh abilities to get landmarks and
know where you're going so they've lost
it yes actual Stars yeah she's got her
she's got her SPS she just pulls it out
tells her where Danny DeVito is it's
usually in L.A oh he's in Alaska this
time he migrated then from where she is
she knows where that is and it gives her
a whole basis for navigating I swear the
podcast is better
better did you also know it's illegal to
feed alcohol to Danny DeVito either
moose or Hunters while they're hunting
moves I'm not sure the the wattage of
the law is very indiscredible do you
have the language of the law there I do
not have the language of the law it just
says there are other moose related laws
as well specifically it's illegal to
feed an alcoholic beverage to one of
them but again does not specify I'm
gonna be hunting you soon moose I'm
sorry I'm not allowed to do this but
here you know this is Jim Beaver Jim
Beamer Beaver no what's the what's the
Jim Beam that here moves just [ __ ]
open your mouth goddamn elk thing go run
I'm gonna shoot you soon I'm sorry moose
I love you
straight from fresh news it's giving
alcohol to the Moose
no alcohol for the Moose what was your
joke I was gonna say you know what that
leaves open you can't drink and hunt and
mooses can't be drunk and get hunted but
a hunter and a moose can bury the
hatchet and sit down and have a drink
and and you know leave that in the past
it's a progressive law which now clearly
is not a progressive law it's just so
you don't get mooses drunk which I feel
like if you have the ability to get a
moose drunk did you really need them to
be drunk for you to have the ability to
get a bullet in them well yeah it's not
a hunt if they just kill them they're
just killing an elaborate thing to get a
moose to get drunk and then you're like
now I'll find him like didn't you did
you already find him I find it hard to
socialize with moose if I'm not both
drunk
really like breaks down the barriers
makes it easier to have that
communication line how often do you find
yourself in Alaska and you need to worry
about this problem not very often
because there's always elk never moves
anyway do you have uh do you have a
bulletin with lead reporter Pam in the
field
sent you via the score what I don't have
Discord open
I do what did you say something
the wordage of the law yes you sent me
the wordage of the law what he sent was
to you and not to me if you want to look
I don't have it well not the exact naked
campfire Tales what the hell is that
that's my Discord I have naked campfire
Tales what is me recording do not
disturb and really do not disturb please
leave me the [ __ ] alone
no one listens to any of them no that's
really uh what you should do is you call
it print server 003 and then no one will
try and get into it moose crime is
waiting
anyway it's also uh it's legal to shoot
bears in this day but it's illegal to
wake them up to take a picture with them
Wake up sleepy well that's clearly a
trap where you're trying to shoot them
and then they don't want Hunters to do
that to them that's rude
is this is this the wordage of the law
this doesn't seem to be the wordage of
the law this is a this is a bunch of
laws of Alaska this is not the wordage
of the law are they good or are they
just regular laws I don't know there's
Alaska do stuff wrong I don't know I've
never been a loose dick no it says moose
drool
idiotic learn to read I can't all right
it's illegal to whisper in someone's ear
illegal issue Bears can't take pictures
with him to wake up it's you can't give
them booze it's illegal to sell stun
guns to Children isn't it isn't that
everywhere
explicitly Alaska is the only ones
worried about stun guns everywhere else
is Chill everyone else's children needs
to be stunned a little bit little shits
it's illegal to speak so loud that you
offend a sensitive person enough to make
him or her leave Fairbanks I would
literally be kicked out
that's literally this is not the wordage
of the law I question you con do you do
not have contact with Pam in the field
article 6 section 9 uh it might be real
Tyler just lied to us live on stream
here Tyler's our fourth member surprise
Tyler's other personality is actually
Pam in the field we've got wrong Tyler
right now
pretending to be Pam but we know the
truth yeah Pam's Alter Ego Tyler as we
all know it's much like darkiplier you
know it's like two in one oh yes the
classic
Tyler Universe we've got Tyler Pam Eve
peep ass these are all just Tyler
personas bratwurst the big kids many
people don't know I am actually just
Tyler in a mess I won't pull it off
right it was me you'll ruin it no I
don't mean to ruin it hey if people
listen to distractible they'll get the
full truth on all of the characters that
Tyler plays he is the genius Mastermind
behind your favorites like dark bliar
Wharf stash Bim trimmer Heap ass of
course
Wade I'm wimp trimmer Bim trimmer you
know
Bim trimmer I'm having the weirdest like
Vegas
today oh you can speak I can't you know
he does it it's harder to tell online
but you can tell by your facial
expressions when you're doing it on oh
my God anyway I've actually been
watching the live numbers of people
checking in our pockets they have been
going down
people are unlistening they're deleting
them they're forgetting that they're
going to that place for me Turtle
Sunshine of the Spotless Mind and
deleting the memories of our podcast
from everybody exactly what they're
doing 100
um so we have not yet earned that listen
but don't worry guys we are endeavoring
to earn that listen uh with more
hard-hitting reporting from Pam in the
field who recently was
almost struck by a vehicle as they were
escaping from the moose hunt
ers
in Alaska
and by doing so discovered
that jaywalking
it's made up
yeah
illegally closed acrossing the street or
having someone named Jay on a leash
which one will that chat decide which
one is it chat
which one is it I don't know why we're
trusting them yeah exactly
uh what were you gonna say Bob uh that
is actually not a an offense in many
places it's far it's been a while since
I've thought about this but it is more
of a nuisance regulation commonly when
it is like in in some sort of law or
whatever and but but that's not like a
misdemeanor that's not a crime nuisance
stuff is more like you know the the cops
might get called because your neighbor
is annoyed by it and the cops will be
like you better not
it's not it's not it is possibly a crime
in some locations so check your local
statutes but it's not actually a crime
as widely as people think it is it's
just stupid to walk in the street
dangerously yeah exactly it absolutely
is it's also stupid to put Jay on a
leash and walk him around let jaywalk
himself however the origins of
jaywalking as a crime
originate from the automotive industry
lobbyists in the automotive industry
wanted to make jaywalking a crime to put
the blame
for accidents where pedestrians are
struck by vehicles on the pedestrians
themselves by shoveling off the burden
of responsibility which is a common
tactic in terms of most things that are
trying to like change people's
perceptions of how things are by
offloading the blame onto the people
that were struck it's like well you
idiots these roads that were clearly
made for Cars and Cars alone like you
shouldn't be walking there you're not
allowed to win this [ __ ] was just
walking down the sidewalk and I'm like
I'm driving here
right
yes thank you
don't look at me Jay is that you Jay is
this J
of the walking Fame
stop walking in all right
so but no it's one of those things where
back in like 1913 was in the early 1920s
when the motor industry was starting to
come and this is like one of the big
things that I'm always like mad about is
the idea of this prevalence that cars
are the quintessential means of
transportation the ultimate end-all
be-all of getting from A to B and I
think being in this Corridor space you
see Ren just earlier riding in on a one
wheel which is one of the most efficient
if a little dangerous ways it's a little
dexterity it takes a little learning
there's a curve to it there's a curve to
it but probably not more dangerous than
cars are people people will slam the
cars all the time but uh it's one of
those things where this idea that cars
are the only way for people to get
around whereas
there are so so many
better ways to get around like I truly
do think that electric bicycles are
going to be the future of I'm gonna go
on a crazy tangent here everyone's gonna
think I'm nuts just because I do like
electric bicycles and I think is I think
it's cool but also when you think about
it the idea of mass transit being in the
form of a car where people especially in
America we were just driving wait you
and I were just driving on the road away
from the Korean barbecue where we were
and it was just one of those things
where we saw this enormous truck like
just take it up next to King Taco it's a
huge blocking whole Lane and King Taco
is like the bed of the truck was Tiny it
was a four-person cabin in the front and
then a truck bed in the background big
wheels what and it was lifted of course
it was lifted it's like why is this even
necessary and most of the time that's
one person driving that vehicle why why
in any fresh health for this truck
that's almost the size of a full bus
which could be holding like 20 30 people
on a slow day taking them around however
is taking up that much space
they
just in Korea and it was just like Seoul
it's it's not even like the best public
transit in the world I think Tokyo is
the best public translator in the world
as far as I know as far as fishing sea
goes and the number of people moving
it's how it's even a mega a megatropolis
the way it is Tokyo I've never been
there but I know I've watched like
documentaries about the intricacies of
Tokyo's like public transit system and
it's like that's how cities should be
because cars literally cause problems
the idea to build more roads to solve
these problems is a lie it is a lie that
has been disproven again and again I'm
sorry am I boring you I was car shopping
am I boring you he's had his phone out
since the moment you started on this
engine
topic you literally said I would go on a
tangent
why did you
use their main stops were and had the
slime mold basically Branch out as it
grows it's very intelligent and
efficient in the sense of it moves
towards the nutrients and then it weans
off the exploratory things and creates
larger veins and so they utilized the
slime mold to design and update the uh
Tokyo subway system all right none of
you could hear that at home no he was
right though he was talking about have
you seen that Mark it's slime it was all
slime all along it was slime 100 slime
all the way down Tokyo's underground is
filled with slime you heard it live here
reporting from Pam Tyler you get a
six-seater for 34k my God you are
hopeless you are hopeless Bob what do
you think about this well the slime mold
thing is really interesting and
absolutely worth watching I've watched
several YouTube mini dock type things
educational videos about that but uh I
think
I mean I think it's inarguable that you
are correct but also aside from
literally tearing down all the
infrastructure in our entire country
it's really complicated to fix both
because of human behavior because
Americans are trained for birth that
your car is like the ultimate mode of
freedom and it's you need a car I'm sure
a lot of people who live in cities don't
need a car and don't live but like if
you live anywhere even in the close
suburbs of a city it's burned into you
that you need a car because you probably
live in the middle of a bunch of
residential area where you need to walk
the mile or more easily to get to the
closest anything that's a store or a
restaurant there's no like you know
casually walking to get groceries I even
live pretty close to a grocery store but
my path between my house and the grocery
the closest grocery store is barely even
bike safe because of the speed limits
and the types of Roads you have to
Traverse God forbid you have to turn
left anywhere so it's a much more
complicated issue than
people just need to start using trains
because the way well the way land Works
legally in our country too getting a
corridor getting like a public easement
to put a train in if there's not
existing land is a nightmare it's
extremely tough especially in City areas
I mean there was there's a history in
some cities of putting when the
interstates were made they put the
interstates right through the I mean
let's be totally honest the the black
neighborhoods and the neighborhoods that
were mostly foreigners or people of
color the people that were mistreated by
society and that were purposefully
neglected those communities were often
sliced right in half or demolished
almost completely by the interstates
when they were put in because there's
nowhere there even when those were built
which was like the first
it's like the late 1900s or the early
20th century I don't remember but even
but at that point in our country's
history there was not a good place to
put public roads or Transit imagine
right now someone trying to come into LA
or New York I mean New York has the
subway but any big city that lacks
substantial Transit that doesn't already
have tunnels or Bridges and everything
built you need where would you put where
would you put a Subway how would you fix
it without just putting buses on the
streets that already dominate all of
that I think that's a valid point and
that is the buses on the street route is
the way you would do it in Translation
Intercity thing people don't realize
that are not in America America is
really really really big and the cities
are really really far away from each
other and we're used to this idea you
drove yeah down here five hours five and
a half hours to get here yeah you just
drove five minutes there's not even a
train I could realistically take ticket
here you can take the Coastal Carolina
but that would I would have to go O2 San
Francisco from where I live and I'm like
an hour and a half outside of San
Francisco and that would take me to
Downtown L.A or wherever the state I
think it's downtown L.A which is not
close to where you live yeah so you
still need the interstitial Transit I
would have to drive to where the to get
onto that train initially I completely
agree for now it's not going to be a big
change with cars in between cities
that's totally valid because that does
represent the kind of freedom in America
and like any place place in cities
however is a completely different story
because there are too many people there
are too many people in cities to
accommodate cars and the more people
there are and as far as we know people
are just moving into cities really
there's not really that many I mean what
is it the population is supposed to
increase by
2 billion globally in the next I forget
in the next like two decades or so
probably it's a lot like it's a 50 in or
no yeah 40 25 it's some huge increase in
the next year however if America was
spread out to actually equally uh
distribute along uh the U.S then cars
would make perfect sense like it would
make absolute sense because they would
never be congregated and absolutely
dense spots like LA because Wade you
were just going through La yesterday it
took you how long to get from LAX to
where I am well I was told it was like a
45 minute drive and it took about what
What minus the 30 minutes about three
hours two to three hours yeah three
hours it took uh three hours to get
across La what's like a 20-minute Drive
in Cincinnati it was about like two
hours here yep yeah and let me tell you
I have electric bike and I'm I love my
electric bike I love it super 73 sponsor
me please for the love of God touch it
isn't that what you have no I don't have
a sponsorship yet no sponsor me I don't
even have a super
[Applause]
why don't I ever get sponsorships I
don't understand I've asked I've asked
so many times I've like I will they
don't do the thing they don't sponsor me
Mark I was just begging oh okay all
right I was just wishing I got nothing
someone called me too
I don't even have hair I'll take a hair
sponsor who
dude
Joe Rogan should sponsor
[Laughter]
we're coming for you go check out the
podcast Link in the description we're
gonna earn that listen we I swear to God
we'll learn that lesson hello
hey how much money
two dollars I hung up on him
does anyone ever and you know what would
be a good 3D print file uh a rack that
you can slam your cell phone down onto
yeah that that when you touch the edge
of the rack it touches the end call
button on your cell phone so when you
need to dramatically get off the phone
you could old school slam it and a bell
in there so when you slam it it's kind
of like green yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
good that's good that's good I got
really distracted with the word rack
what are we talking about
oh it's the name of the podcast I swear
we called it that exclusively for him
you can all see it now this podcast is a
delight it is so worth your time there's
a link in the description I'm begging
you I swear if you go down the
description there's both the YouTube
channel Spotify there's links you can go
search for it take the moment right now
to go look at it I we're gonna take a
quick commercial break and we'll be
right back with you we'll be right I got
a piece that's good but we'll be right
back with you yeah it's in the
description thank you so much for your
time your love your feelings your belief
in us and me me we all of us me don't
look at me
the Royal we yes we'll be right back
oh thank God I can't see what's smarter
than
this you've known to me for 10 years
I make distractible what it is and
should be how do you know that you don't
know that you don't know anybody you're
right I don't you're so much smarter you
got a big brain in there you're a huge
brain I turned that off for recording
you got a big brain use it Bob you're
doing great do you have it no do we have
any do we have any philosophy news
stories oh philosophy well I can talk
about philosophy like content ethics
utilitarianism save it save it love it
you got anything we can relate back time
oh I got something about mosquitoes
mosquitoes are a pretty good food for a
source for a lot of things do you know
possums are actually really good for
your yard because possums eat spiders
yeah
that's impossible but you need spiders
to eat the other bugs so like the
spiders it's like it's like the chain a
food chain if you will of like existing
no actually you know things like nothing
you know things like knowledge to share
you don't bring this out when we're live
to the people yeah God no why why they
would love it because I can't think with
the cameras on stress too much stress
but yeah the listeners stand a smart
wait have you seen have you seen the
subreddit no I don't look at things they
think you're the smartest one they want
you to attack the right philosophy I am
but you don't why would you not
possums eat ticks breaking news from
Molly in the field Molly
I did not know that I honestly okay
possums are actually good to have around
a lot of things you want to talk about
the possible I technically didn't finish
the discussion on
modernization of Transportation but I
mean what do we feel like that had a lot
of philosophical things yeah wait do you
want how about the philosophy of mass
transit
oh there's so much the moral the moral
obligation of of serving Humanity with
Public Works obligation also depends on
which moral theory you subscribe to okay
Mark and I will wander off and and what
is your moral obligation is a moral
obligation to the world to humanity to
the betterment of humanity or to the
betterment of society as a whole which
would include you know people this would
be and creatures gold content for when
we're live on screen yeah are you able
to talk about this do you wanna
let's do you want to try do you want to
go back live yeah and then just skip
gift Wade free reins and do whatever
he's going to do yeah you take your pick
Wade will start on you okay and you just
run with it you give them the gold that
I know is in your head got it
oh
all right don't let me know when we come
back
do we have a countdown oh I'm on TV hey
God boobs are great
oh we're gonna we'll be right back
commercial break oh all right um too
much pressure it was right on me what do
you mean do you want it do you need a
lead in do you want one of us yeah yeah
one of you who needs to like put the
ball in the tee for me all right I will
I will lob you an unmissable softball I
will come back okay and then you just
jump off all right let's do it okay all
right break down three give us a
countdown loud and proud
give us the countdown
hey in Tyler's credit he was doing a
very good countdown
countdown I'm proud
sorry for that quick double commercial
break but we're back now I hope you've
checked out the link in the description
and follow the podcast Mark how are the
numbers trending the numbers are
trending down excellent bad that will
improve that good we can prove that
we'll earn your listen I'm looking at
the wrong thing camera hey what's up but
we were talking talking before the break
about mass transit and the issues
surrounding transitioning America
towards better mass transit but there's
a deeper question around this Wade
I think you might have something to
offer
why is mass transit better for society
is it better for society is there an
obligation
to improve it in our nation oh it gets
so complicated yeah all right well look
if you are thinking about mass transit
you're also thinking about whether or
not like highways are good and highways
are always expanding right like out here
you've got like six eight lanes and
since they either expanded we're getting
more and more lanes and more Lanes means
less environment less nature which means
less land for animals and things to
exist so if you're talking about for the
world mass transit like that is probably
bad but if you're getting rid of
individualized cars Vehicles buses that
kind of thing and you're doing more like
a train or multiple trains especially
like the fast trains or whatever where
you can have more on one line and not
having to have like multiple railroads
or underground Subways I'm sure Subways
are probably bad in some ways too like
you guys don't even have basements out
in California because of earthquakes so
would a Subway work here would that be
dangerous because I don't really know if
any West Coast cities have buried train
systems the Bay has street cars I don't
believe there's any if or much if any
Underground
trains in the bay any kind of flooding
like if uh like what happened in New
Orleans if that kind of thing happened
here and you guys had like a subway
system and that got flooded I don't even
know how you would start to clear that
out other than like some major pumps and
that kind of thing but even that has to
be bad for the environment to some
extent right digging holes underground
you're getting rid of like worms and
that kind of thing so
I mean people are probably the worst
thing for the world or how about for the
world but if we're just focused on
ourselves which is a very human thing to
do then still you get to a point where a
city is going to get so big the
population is going to get so big where
you can't have everyone having their own
cars and their own method of
transportation even if you imagine
there's flying cars and people can go up
and around and next to each other the
amount of horrible accidents that would
cause by people not paying attention you
will eventually need to find a more like
singular way of transportation where
people can go in Mass amounts rather
than one at a time
ah
the BART system goes under the bay
oh that's true there is a tunnel I've
ridden that train a BART system
um yeah okay I okay uh we need to take a
quick commercial break uh it's uh we got
a lot of sponsors coming at you we got
more action coming at you do you like
boobs like us well do we have nothing
break oh um
do you want information or do you want
Tits McGee no there's a middle ground
there's middle ground there's Middle
Ground between the boobs okay
I love you you get smart Wade you get
dumb ways what about I got two forks
it's got two prongs what about clever
clever Wade [ __ ] jokes are cleverish
witty what about witty witty Wade
that's the dumb one yeah witty is not
dumb it can be both You Gotta Be Clever
to be dumb sometimes you gotta be real
clever yeah but I I I get that but are
you it's not quite like there's the fool
which is making a very clever witty
jokes good song too and then you you
boob jokes and Dick Jokes which is we we
want to elevate ourselves beyond what
the other people think of our podcast
satirical way satirical
he's here he's your your smarts to to to
look I know I carry this thing but you
all put a little bit too much weight on
me sometimes
um
how about we just move on top of
it like I am the the cabin of the plane
and you guys are the wings sure like you
help but like can't go anywhere without
the cabin and it gets a little bit too
pressure sometimes
what if we just let Wade put a button on
it and describe how he'd fix public
transportation and then move on all
right yeah we'll give you a chance you
do sure do what you do what do you want
great all right be smart so
um maybe before we come back from
commercial you said you wanted like a
bathroom break or something
I already went we're good we could all
go to together and just get over with
real quick
group potty
yeah he's one in front two on the sides
like human centipede of peeing more like
a fountain
okay
maybe the next break
okay yeah sure
all right you ready Wade I'm good I'm
ready to button I gotta solve all the
world's problems in one quick sentence
okay done like a two or two or three
sentences
a good idea all right
Tyler count us down Tyler
now okay we're back everyone welcome uh
to button this up to get rid of our
transportation talk I think we're gonna
wrap it up we can all give our Solutions
our ideas for a solution I think right
now we've got too many cars too many
people uh and the world needs less of
that so that way we're inclined to want
to fix the issues so what we do is we
give everybody a balloon and they put it
on their car and some of the balloons
are set to Auto inflate to a point where
it lifts them and their car into space
and then they're no longer our [ __ ]
problem
wow
all right good enough all right thank
you so much uh we are distractible
people
um we love oh are we gonna do another
animation act we have another
erect oh we have another and we have
another animations bring it over ladies
wow can I just say for a second I just I
I'm looking at look at the views and
likes on this
look at the views and likes on this nice
uh Tyler pull up the pull show the
people what what they're seeing here
show the people
no no you could I don't want to see look
at this
adpg adventure chat in there put the
chat in there put that get the chat in
there
you have to chat in there get that chat
yeah there we go so I want everyone to
take a look at this see that other
animation that we posted I don't care
about numbers I don't care about numbers
look at this one 5.5 million views oh
that's a good video as opposed to July
of this year 398
000 likes
furiously oh not like that no what oh
what what's happening it was just there
you just saw it
ooh
no hey an innovation here
it was there
I don't what there
look at this look at this see look at
this see September
two months
one-fifth of the views this is what I'm
talking about
this is why we're turning down
you know one third of the line and whose
fault is it Mark
I don't know the fourth fifth and sixth
uh sort of inviting you to it's I think
it's my fault if I'm honest what I've
been on a huge downtrend since Bob's
fridge everyone has made it very clearly
that that is the funniest episode of any
episodic content across the entire world
that's ever been created and that's why
people constantly still ask me how my
fridge is doing uh and I've just been
like I've fallen off and and you guys if
anything you guys have picked it up
especially you weighed maybe lots of
bangers maybe you've had some good but I
think I'm I'm the bottom of the triangle
if we're if we're like a triangle well
bring up the stream bring up uh talk can
you bring up the Stream
kind of like
let's take a look can you I'm just
curious at the motion if you go like
this and like pinch as hard as you can
and then just let it go then it just
slides and my nails dig in and it hurts
my hand your nails dig in keep it keep
them flat I don't yeah and then snap
I snap better like this but I'm watching
this and I'm not impressed with this
level of content because it's like just
snapping doesn't feel like a very
compelling kind of thing that you could
do right I feel like we can innovate
these a little more because if you look
compared to like even a million views on
the last one we only got 28 000 views
here like that really great likes we
could do the supernatural thing whenever
they're like investigating the Asylum
and uh Dean drops his uh patient shorts
and he shakes his penis around and goes
Pudding we could do that is that in the
show yeah when
oh man is that show that we talked about
your [ __ ] about for being terrible
after season five the first time I can't
believe our tier list episodes were more
controversial than the beta episode I
know I guess we're bad baiters yeah I
guess it's good the title didn't work
yeah it was originally going to be
called masterbaters but I guess we're
not so it's not yeah I guess not
anyway guys take a moment right now to
give this stream a like why not share it
with a friend because this is an
entirely selfish Endeavor where in the
past we have asked to for you to help us
out with this for reasons of charitable
purpose this is only selfish we are here
for us and us alone
it just felt like a Sarah Mclaughlin
rant it is it is absolutely
we're stooping to new lows to help earn
that listen and if we don't have more
people here to earn the listen from
because we've earned all of your listens
so basically we've squeezed you out like
a wreck and we were throwing you away
right now so you can go fetch more Rags
with which to bring in and then we can
squeeze go get my Rags go get more Rags
hey it works on them
go share so we can bring more people in
here what happening
that's why there's two and behind the
singing [ __ ] and we can't handle it
we're like oh he's trying to tell us a
message what's the message Tyler window
oh I see what he's doing there is better
yeah yeah no in this scene they can't
hear us anymore no we're not in the
scene you are actively
Studio yeah we're previewing we're in
there Mark how are babies made
um
is this is a q a Time listen I'm not
done ringing people out here we could do
three-headed expert everyone loves that
and we always do a good job we please
know and uh and you I and stop love stop
it guys Chad if you don't know what 300
expert is we're definitely gonna do that
later on so stick around in the
description there's a link to our lovely
podcast but we've already squeezed all
of the listen juice out of you we need
more people in here but we haven't
squeezed all the money out of you yet so
get people do everything possible to
make this stream and its amazing quality
touch the hearts of so many more people
like
comment share it with your friends
family enemies whoever
and help spread the Glorious word of us
what were you saying
you mock what what were you saying
[Music]
[Laughter]
amazing
I don't know what we say uh I was doing
the rags pit they were they're just rags
to us and we need more Rags so we can be
right you just gotta squeeze on we will
I would love to get more rags
was that all you were going to say
I have a problem with me do you have a
problem with me talking with my hands no
we're just here in the same place so I
can see what you're doing and I'm next
to you it's so enticing ah fine whatever
it's fine it's not even mocking
what
how even
it's not even a reaction either if you
have to anything
it's like a weird canned reaction played
in the back of your mind oh my god oh
wow that's incredible we're not real
people we're context creators
I do I unironically love Bob's Rich
because I remember the recording of it
very special I've never met that whole
day was quite the thing I can't imagine
your end of it I was in Canada right
yeah I was filming the edge of sleep for
those of you who don't know the edge of
sleep as a TV show is going to be coming
out I haven't going to talk about it in
a bit but
um yeah I was in a closet in this Airbnb
I was in up in Canada and I was in this
closet and I had this ice vest on
because it was so unbelievably hot I had
a laptop to record with but even my
laptop was still incredibly warm and I
remember we got in there because we were
like we got to record distractible you
know we're keeping up with this first
like month or two of actually doing it
yeah we weren't ahead we were kind of
like we need this this is next week's
episode and I was still in Canada and
busy filming
um and I was in there and you were a
little late or something and then you
just came back like
well didn't it start I was I showed up a
little late like I usually do and then
we were like talking for a minute and
then I was like oh
they text the fridge guys who are
supposed to be here this afternoon just
texted me that they're 10 minutes away
right and they say they can't come at
any other time yeah and then I was like
well I texted them back and then the
doorbell rang and I think I literally
went ah
I have to go right though and we just
stopped and you guys were like okay
let's know when you're done like I
shouldn't be long it's just afraid it's
delivery how long could it take man but
I I do remember that it was interesting
a little late there tie a little light
there low light
it's okay it's okay man it's okay it's
okay it's okay man it's okay okay calm
down it's gonna be okay
but it was it was a very lovely time and
I I do remember because it was like the
first episode that we pointed to that
people were like okay
I get it I get what this show could be
about this podcast could be about I get
what it's about and it's it's always
just been about capturing this uh like
friendship that we've had for a very
long time and if I could be just like
super real for a moment I am very lucky
to be where I am and to be able to do
something with these guys here still
after all this time many of you watching
this may not have been here since the
very beginning some of you certainly
have been but many of you may not to
know that after 10 years of doing all of
this crazy YouTube stuff that we're
still sitting here and we're doing the
same exact thing we did 10 years ago in
my mom's kitchen and we don't hate each
other we surprisingly don't hate each
other uh dude they see us this setup
they see here the original setup I think
we all had webcams yeah webcams but in
the middle of this of his mom's kitchen
table dining room table there was a
stack of whatever books or crap we could
find yeah
blue yeti with a sock on it stacked up
on the middle of the table yeah and that
was our audio
if you were here at the start when we
were Mark was having a spasm about the
the audio quality and we were doing all
that [ __ ] the audio quality that
started this was so much better than any
of the original charity streams we did
in your Mom's Kitchen absolutely we used
to pack up our computers from our house
yes put them in our car drive them over
the night before the stream torture Wade
with the styrofoam of me getting out my
my monitor that I had that was always in
squeaky foam it was just so crazy to
think about and there has been some
people here that have been like who are
these guys and I'm like how do you not
know who these guys are fake fans Wade
and Bob obviously yeah exactly which
ones which wait and Bob this is Bob
no Tyler
this is wrong I'm Wade
me I'm Bob no wait a minute emails I get
already okay I've totally forgot that
the blue yeti with a sock on it as if
the plosives would even be a factor that
far away I just knew that they needed
some like I didn't even understand how a
microphone worked that was 10 years ago
and it's crazy to see that we are still
here doing the same thing which is like
goofing around on a stream that's very
I'm very fortunate to be able to do that
I'm very lucky that you guys watching
this have somehow enabled us to be able
to do this and as always with everything
we do we somehow stumble our way into
success
um and this is a testament to like
us and what we've done I know most
podcasts are just like three friends
talking
but I think we have in a more pure way
than any other podcast out there
distilled just that as the only thing
carrying us forward the only element of
this pocket is just we're just three
dudes that are talking and we've somehow
catapulted that to the top 20 of the
podcast well and it's exemplified by the
way that we do episodes because other
other podcasts Tyler knows this pain are
uh like researched there's usually like
a writer on staff our producers I can't
even remember I would say more episodes
than not we showed up to record and all
caught on and it was like who's hosting
[ __ ] do you guys have any ideas I got
something I guess I'm hosty today [ __ ]
yeah and then we just come up with the
idea on the spot and some of those have
turned into I don't want to spoil it but
wasn't ways words and on the spot
situation I think so or did you have
that one that one was on the spot I
think and that was one that I know
people have really liked it comes up on
the side sometimes we'll come up like a
rough idea and one of us like will get a
bigger idea from it and we'll like I'm
gonna store that one away but usually we
show up and either it's like oh I'm
gonna go talk to Molly or Amy or Mandy
see if they have any ideas do you guys
have anything uh we could we could do uh
God we do uh getting older again you
wanna do that one
goddamn recording session I appreciate
that people liked that episode after the
fact I have never felt worse about
myself in the context of making anything
with you guys as like an on-screen
performer or whatever yeah maybe on tour
I have had that same level of shame but
that was a that made me feel bad for
weeks after it
say this again the the worst piece of
[ __ ] episode ever that was so funny I
know so funny I was so sincerely just
like no I've got a great topic working
older
that we had just released that one like
a month and a half early it wasn't
leaving like that long ago no but it was
so fun I know it turned out to be funny
but I that was such a hard Dent to my
confidence in the place so we went
through like what 30 minutes before any
of us realized yeah it was true none of
us knew that we'd done it I think there
was I don't remember I swear early on I
think maybe you were like I only talked
about this before and Mark and I were
both like keep going no
this is a good idea oh man but I do pay
attention sometimes sometimes sometimes
yeah definitely sometimes but it is
lovely to be here
um but I do want to say something I have
not gotten confirmation yet but there is
a special reward if you guys help
catapult us to International stardom
which is a very small ask I know it's
fine all you got to do is click the link
in the description below it's right down
there take a moment now because and
here's it we're going to earn that
lesson if you do
we are going to call in
a mythical person that is been missing
from this equation for so so long if
right now in the next 30 seconds you
click the link listen to an episode the
entirety of it in 30 seconds go listen
to it right now
or follow it and go back whatever it is
I don't know
we will call in a very special person
that many people have been desperately
desperately desperately asking for more
of
at least on Spotify I think you can
download episodes for later too their
name has five letters in it
that's the only hint I'll give that's
the only hint I'll give
so do you are you spelling that right
yeah
yeah
I'm feeling right
why should I think it's a mystery for
all of us
maybe I don't know how people spell
their names when you get right now and
this is only right now click the link in
the description check out this podcast I
swear to you it's worth your time and as
a special reward for that beautiful
effort that you put into this we're
gonna call that special
special someone that and our only fans
will pretend to scratch you on the head
and tell you you're a good boy or good
girl Waits ASMR intermission is coming
up soon I got to listen to that while I
do it bring the mic with you that's the
that's the ASMR I'm gonna check I'm
gonna check the numbers just make sure
that we're actually trending in the
right direction for the first time and
not actually going drastic I'm sure we
are checking out what's spelled hey me
special guest a-a-m-y-y
it's
it's Santa
oh they're all Santa will be here live
that's no good that's just an anagram
for Satan
it could be Satan oh my God it's very
red all around us we might be in Hell
already who knows it might be we might I
thought of porn but I guess it could be
hell it could be it could be it does the
same no no if they're the same then I
want to be
right
those are
did Satan just cross behind you yeah all
right for those of you who are want to
listen to an episode and
are we gonna act out the the thingy hold
on no I'm gonna call okay you're right
we should act out in the time if you
don't like what you're seeing in front
of your face then we're gonna do this
special call
so it's freshman year I wanted to do
like an activity what I tried to do was
parkour and it was like supposed to be a
quote unquote beginner Park
okay so wait hold on there was a
technical confusion you can hear the
video there was a technical confusion
everybody hold on stop
wait a minute
fill my cup
put some liquor in
it put your show we don't need us we're
gonna reenact this episode for you oh
[ __ ] good I mean yep which one is this
uh Mark broke his ass
what am I gonna laugh I forget oh you
did that oh boy thanks guys
do it Mark I thought we were gonna fight
um
so it's freshman year I wanted to do
like an activity what I tried to do was
parkour and it was like supposed to be a
quote-unquote beginner parkour thing
I showed up at the place and we met in
the parking garage and it was me and
three other dudes and one of them had
done parkour maybe and the other one
three of us were just like complete
newbies getting in there and just trying
to have an adventure we were jumping
around the fourth level of the parking
garage and so we were leaving around
there we were jumping around we would go
like over the edge
with like 50 feet did I say like this
many times of this oh we would just like
dance around there for a little bit and
so we actually ended up like dropping
down two floors anyway but the stairs or
the ramp inside so like crawling around
the building outside and I don't die at
this point pause
do I say like this much in my normal
conversation but no you don't normally
say like this much
all right continue
I don't die at this point but we get
down to the second level and it's time
to drop from the Second Story and do a
sweet tuck and roll into this little
grass patch so the first guy goes and he
goes like dropped and tuck and roll and
it's perfect and he's fine and then the
second guy goes and he manages to do it
a tuck and roll and it's at this point
that I realize they assumed I knew how
to do a tuck and roll
which I had never done in my life
so there I am hanging off by one hand
from the Second Story ledge of a
concrete parking garage looking at a
tiny patch of grass that I'm supposed to
hit and in my head I'm like it can't be
that hard
and so they're all giving me encouraging
words really you can do it and I'm like
I got this i got this and so I drop
and I landed from the second story
straight onto my ass like 100 full on
into my ass I felt something pop weirdly
no pain but like this done thing where
you're like on the ground like uh am I
dead am I dead and like weirdly pause
I do not remember saying like this many
times you've got to be kidding me I did
not say like this many times well you're
saying it this much right now so it's
literally no way I'm gonna try to remove
all the likes from the rest of this and
give this a better retelling because
this is absolutely asinine there's no
way that I've done this this is not who
I am I'm a better person than this wow
like seriously there we go
I assumed totally fine I wasn't by the
way I want to mention I was not okay uh
and then the guy behind me is about to
go and oh my God
instead of falling on his ass he fell on
his face
his legs hit he went forward he did not
roll right into his face and chest hit
the ground and you just hear him go
oh oh God like no just all the wind
dropped out of him and he's desperately
on the ground trying to get a sucking
breath so you know after a while we're
just standing there we're looking at
this guy dying on the ground really what
do we do but he gets up he's he gets up
and he plays it off I'm fine but clearly
his ribs are broken straight up his ribs
are broken and so he gets up he's
looking good I think I think I need I
think I'm good for two day guys I'm
gonna lay down so it's he stumbles off
and we're watching him we watch him walk
away for five minutes so we're watching
him stumble away about the time he
disappears out of you behind you no
those Hills like we look at each other
really all right let's keep going guys
let's see we go over to this building we
get to the roof we are Sirens when we're
up on the roof for some reason in our
brain we're they're coming for us they
found out we went into the forbidden
zone and you know they're gonna get us
on this roof we've committed horrible
crimes so we all Panic right so we panic
and we run off and then again they drop
down from this second story ledge onto
this grassy part so I find myself once
again hanging by one hand from a second
story ledge looking down but in my mind
in my mind at this moment I'm okay I
went backwards that last time I'll go
forwards this time I know what my
mistake was yeah he learned it
and so I drop and I'm forward forward
forward I saw them roll on their
shoulder and so my legs hit the ground I
go forward
and I put a hundred percent of my way
right onto my shoulder and I don't move
and it's just I hit the ground my
shoulder just
well thank God
hey dude I
uh I don't remember
oh I'm down for this is this me for a
while and I'm oh God I'm okay okay I'm
okay and I look up and they're gone
[Laughter]
why did you make it they taught you
[Laughter]
I think the only way that could be
better at all is if you look up and
there's like two cops just standing
there
it's like we know if only we were that's
the Forbidden roof I hope they lost
their parkour teaching license after
this did you guys know there's a Bob's
fridge animation oh guys there's several
of them and they're all really good
they're all really good all right you
can Torture Me by making me do a song no
not now we have to do the special call
they the people the call for those of
you who don't know we're doing a special
reward promotional thing for
distractible only in the past 30 seconds
it's already over to be
why do you make fun of me I thought that
was the thing I thought when you talked
about it
I'm trying to help
I'm trying
I'm trying to earn that listen because
if you click the link in the description
below and start listening to
distractible if you haven't already
please please please please please
please please do I will call
very special person
who you all know and love
the one and the only
person
who's so special in near and dear to our
hearts
please do
thank you
and I'm calling them
and you at least show us the caller ID
uh yeah in a moment uh flip to my camera
hey buddy say hi to the Stream
Tyler's here yeah
Tyler
[Applause]
I can't believe it man everyone was so
excited to see you they I I was sorry
will you couldn't be here live
um but honestly like it's just such a uh
there's like a weird echo in your
background I don't know your phone voice
is coming out through oh that's okay man
we'll figure that out but anyway uh this
is for all the lovely people that click
that link in the description this this
man uh what could I say I'll let him
talk for himself
hey you guys should definitely Listen to
distractible It's the best podcast on
every podcasting platform if you don't
know they definitely passed Joe Rogan
for like three weeks at least so uh you
should definitely check it out it's
hilarious it has the funniest three
people that I know in my entire life on
it as hosts uh that they rotate out
um one of them's a little crazier than
the other and likes to talk about
private parts but ignore that part
sometimes
um at the end of the day some of the
best people in the world are on this
podcast and you should check it out
that's so sweet that's so sweet of you
and I know everyone is it really misses
you uh they hope you're doing well yeah
I heard you died yeah
no
[Music]
no uh well AI is getting pretty Advanced
these days and um I miss you
um
wish you were here I think we all do
um rest in peace buddy
I've only got his lower half in my phone
nothing it's a different AI
that's a new it's a new iPhone feature
it's the Herm it's the modern Herm
abstractable
about who the hell is that
what
it's it's what happened anyway the OG
distractible fans which after this point
has been over a year there are
officially OG distractible fans if you
are an OG distractible fans and you 100
do know
do know
that you are better than all the new
people that are coming in today
except you knew people that are checking
out the live stream for the
you all right bud
is there something behind me no no
there's nothing behind me no uh you're
just a man there's nothing behind me
okay I'm a thing that's fine yeah
definitely fine yeah anyway
um
new fans are better than old fans
everyone knows us right guys that's like
the exact opposite of what you were just
saying out loud which is it Mark hell I
don't know which is it Mark what is
going to get people to listen to The
Look new fans are cooler than old fans
because they're just now discovering
this great thing that they've been
missing out on and so they're cool now
because they're finally here but old
fans are just better than new fans
because they've known
that's why I'm the best because I'm the
oldest of the three of us are you
by uh two months wow everyone thinks I'm
like 10 years older than YouTube because
I aged faster or something but I'm only
two months older than Mark only two
months well you guys are way older than
me yeah your baby your birthday's coming
up
on Tuesday yeah wow
follow holy [ __ ] distractible birthday
wish for my birthday if you want to do
something for me if you want to really
give me what I want for my birthday
birthday wish
followed follow distractible and listen
I wish you would listen my birthday wish
you would listen oh my God wait no I
gotta get this in full screen don't
worry about it it's fine
I don't know oh yeah it was pure s
[Laughter]
ometimes
[Laughter]
it's a birthday wish yeah I'm gonna be
old we're getting older we're getting
older I don't know if you heard about
that anywhere what you doing bud I'm
switching cameras to who's talking and
uh and and in my old age uh it's it's
sometimes hard to you know it's hard to
hear and I and I get lost just going to
the grocery store and it's okay buddy we
all have things like that happen life
gets harder you know and uh but it would
really it would really cheer me up if
someone some of you would just listen to
distractible as a birthday gift to me a
birthday gift for Bob listen to
distractible yes thank you grandson yes
I'm yeah I'll take it yeah that's a
compliment I was a grandson but I'm old
you don't even know what to do when I
say something I know it's not mean to
you I don't know how to handle it it's
it's but seriously though October 18th
is my birthday okay
and I'm 83 years old
so we don't have a long time left if
we're going to get to the top of the
world in podcast
land we're dying this world the top of
the podcast World we're not going to get
there before I die unless you just go
right now and fall 83 it's a miracle
I've made it this far I look pretty good
for 83 I think but you should follow the
podcast and listen to it there's a link
in like the description or if you just
type distractible podcasts or even just
distractible I bet it'll come up every
year we get older is one less year we
have to live
that's ain't that the truth you're
telling me you young whippersnapper how
old are you did you say 83 this year you
well we just said he's the youngest of
us so that makes us 83 Plus
something wrong with your wig
yeah uh anyway I'm gonna be so
disappointed I will be inconsolable if
you don't give me my birthday wish yes
yes please please
please everyone there at home listening
to this it is
the most sincere birthday wish it's his
dying birthday wishes this is actually
the birthday I die so
it is my it is my last wish I I feel
like we were in sincerity for a little
moment and I think we're stretching into
insincerity unless there's something new
it's okay because it's distractible
no sorry I'll keep it sincere okay I'm
cool
uh tell your friends that it is Bob's
birthday because that was actually one
of the biggest pushes it was my birthday
uh after Bob's Furniture came out it was
my birthday and I made it my birthday
wish for people to check out
distractible and people really actually
truly showed up for that moment that was
really sincere it was very sweet because
I I very rarely like care about my
birthday that much
um and uh it's it's one of the things
that gets to date but I actually made a
wish and I was like please do and look
at that well people love you Mark I
don't know people will do anything for
you I don't I don't know if I have the
same sort of
devotion I don't Inspire the I don't
have a tasteful nude calendar well some
of the big
[Music]
ger Bob all of my business emails are to
you
that's true but all of my business
emails are to you so we have
the chat from us oh well that's nice but
I'd rather you listen to the podcast I
hope we appreciate it this is Mark's
Channel
you know what's great about this gift
you could give to me for my birthday is
it's free that's true it doesn't cost
you a single penny if all of this money
that people are trying to contribute to
us instead they buy like Google ad
credits and they create micro ad
campaigns they like get because if I'm
saying like God I'm saying it
you say like a lot man apparently I do I
don't even notice it but isn't there
like if
isn't there a free isn't there something
similar to a free like initial credit
like 50 free
advertising put another Penny in The
like jar
there are 50 dollar free trial something
for Google ads that you can sign up for
and if you were going to give us
money anyway why not
so that you could help spread the word
of distractible I bet Twitter is
desperate for people to try their
advertising system because uh they're
probably bleeding money
Facebook meta is dying but they're all
about the ads if you
like exploit these systems that they've
set up for themselves
in honorable ways that won't get us sued
and you spread the word of no don't
don't do it I was another Super Chat for
50 seconds how many Impressions that is
what if it was like a 10 CPM that that
would be 5 000 people your ads could
have reached
yeah what if it wasn't like a 10. P.M
you should hey if you post ads on
Twitter people could like them they
could like them
and you're allowed to say that life I'm
allowed to say any like that I want yeah
go to the distractible YouTube and leave
a like
that leave a like on this stream right
now
spread the word
I think you're all looking over the very
intelligent plan that we have that's
pretty interesting we're going to create
a cohesive advertisement any kind of ad
that they want to as long as it's
positive in the world and not you know
or a horrifying or racist or anything if
you you could make a phone video Yeah of
your own self talking about why you like
distractible that and then you could
give me ads for my birthday this is this
is a viral ad campaign to happen I
actually truly don't think anyone's done
this where they have crowd-sourced the
ad campaign itself well most companies
and or Brands really are scared of what
people might post but you're cool we
have trust you we trust you to do this
for us it's real easy and if it's a
really good one wheel I will our own
dollars behind it I will absolutely uh
take it and run it on things my self if
if some people create really really
awesome like viral Grassroots personal
thing you could record a sketch you
could do a drawing or an animation what
any kind of thing you want to make that
that you could talk about why you like
this if you like our podcast someone
just said would would elf allow this do
you think what elf has any say in what
we do as a podcast do you think anybody
has a say or want to say and what we do
as a podcast we are a rogue element what
elf is shaking in their boots every time
we have an idea yeah we took it off
YouTube because we wanted to
no I'm dead serious right is this genius
or is this highly illegal I can't tell
and I'm thinking it's possibly either
one but in a very strong way this might
be the most incredibly genius
genius illegal idea we've ever had
because think of it if everyone here
gets a ten dollar free credit there's
what 28 000 people here right now that's
280 000 of pure advertising money is
that actual math wow yeah ten dollar if
everyone you need to put any money in to
get the credit probably have to put your
credit card in but hey uh steal your
mom's
[Music]
I'm glad this is on the Markiplier
channel not the distractible one
go to the card you find go for it
no there's more Super Chat that could
have been a thousand Impressions
seriously why are you doing this what's
wrong with you people wrong with you
don't give us money give Google money
don't steal your mom's credit card yeah
can you bring close to me
I don't condone stealing your mom's
credit card neither does whoever this is
you shouldn't I don't suggest it it was
uh people on the internet today I would
can you uh cut to weight real quick and
then come back to me don't look at me
and my misjudgment I was not thinking
clearly when I suggested people and I
what what I was gesturing at Wade
continue we were looking at me
well I'm between you wait's behind a
microphone stand for me
I want to be very clear I am only
apologizing for the very obvious joke
that I said earlier that I will not
reiterate I am not apologizing for the
genius campaign genius idea the
crowdsourced advertising I believe there
is creativity in all of you and I don't
think that creativity has to rely on
stealing your mom's credit card
I'm in the clear legally
I don't think our viewers are that
stupid they would never so what happened
to me they wouldn't you're all out of
your frame like you're slouching I guess
I am too
oh good yeah thank you
there we go perfect no I I'm so I'm so
I've never thought of this I have never
seen that I'm trying to think of viral
advertising stuff if I've ever seen
anything like this people have gotten uh
communities to like and often not for
good reasons and for good results have
gotten like comment bombs yeah and
review bombs on things which is like
driving the community and sometimes it's
good frequently it's not good no
um this this specifically trying to use
like your free any free ad credits on
Google AdSense or on the Twitter thing
and instead of donating cash to this
which is really
not necessary at all can we look this up
and see like how easy I'm looking okay
Snapchat has advertisings if you you get
a 375 credit if you spend 350. so you do
have to spend on something on Snapchat
okay yeah Snapchat you can start with
just five notes
isn't Snapchat like dying no no actually
it's not like doing better than ever
really look hey
listen
if you help us with this there are
creative people if you click draw an MS
paint thing make a video there's that
one uh video with me the gun and me hey
wake up
oh that one yeah make sure it like that
put it out in the world we're really
leveraging the internet's kind of broken
infrastructure of analytics and
advertising but we're using it for good
purposes right we're using it for good
it's very it seems like it's selfish
just to benefit us but but you love us
you know what we can definitely say
we're using it for our purposes which
are not bad yes which means they're
probably good these are good purposes I
I want people in chat right now to say
whether or not this is a good idea or a
bad can we get a poll can we get a poll
up it's my YouTube channel Tyler my
YouTube channel I have to do the poll by
the way
Tyler type that poll together
oh what did you do you do what did you
do
[Laughter]
did you send everyone this Tyler or just
me
oh
there's a list of places that Tyler sent
where you can get free ad credit to
promote uh different stores read them
Shopify and they what's this website let
me see what the website is Shopify is
what our merch is on well Shopify David
Linder whoever you are you wrote this
article credit to you Shopify is one
they give steps to 12 steps to doing
Shopify Facebook uh you can make an
account and use it inactive after a few
days you'll get a response and give you
ad credit there uh being Yahoo either
one of those apparently you can do it at
Bluehost
uh and that's all that's in this
particular article
so it's always one of those spend ones
get ones there's got to be one or if you
guys have these five dollars you keep
giving to us for some reason if you put
that in your ad you would have gotten
like five dollars for your five dollars
so why don't you
you know yeah is it like you have to
spend 500 to get 500 or is it up to 500
to get up to 500. people are saying it's
genius 50 genius this idea is 50 genius
that's 30 illegal but genius which is
also genius and then not only 19 highly
suspect that's overwhelmingly genius
that's overwhelmingly and only somewhat
illegal they don't know if it's illegal
but for all of you people who would
ordinarily give superjets which I don't
know why you would clearly we've been
ignoring them we can spread what if we
would I will zoom on me zoom on me zoom
on me genius moment
what if these ad platforms themselves
have advertised in them and then we can
promote the podcast on the platform for
other people that actually listen to
podcasts to listen to them zoom on Wade
no
is great don't zoom on me Bob
I mean that's an excellent idea you must
be able to advertise on Spotify you can
definitely advertise on on Google for
Google
what's that called Google podcast yeah
there's gotta there's this there's
angles there's levels there's directions
and also it's inspired and genius chat
this could be the most groundbreaking
game-changing thing we've ever done I've
never I've leveraged the power of the
community to do great things now finally
after 10 years of pretending to be good
we can use it for evil and selfish gains
do you agree to go evil with us I'm
making another poll
go evil with us uh Tyler type up the
poll what were the results oh hey there
they are yeah
50 genius 30 genius but illegal
18 par sent something not in this chat
really started moving
has anyone tried this tell us if it
works
if you've done it if you've looked and
if it's illegal it was Mark's idea yeah
if it's illegal it's all Wade's idea I
can't imagine how this would be illegal
I don't see how is it illegal it's it's
money for advertising these companies
all put advertising out do I talk with
my hands a lot normally yeah I don't
know you know what you do on every
content you do don't know two or three
times you've done it but you should
definitely do it because I think it's
engaging when you do it the weird thing
was before when you were talking you
were also doing this as you were talking
about doing this there's no way I was
doing billions of crap trying to do a
mating dance but I liked it it was good
I don't know oh why is it on me God damn
it
no I mean it it makes total sense
because we have the power of the people
but also the power of the people have
has aged up with us and now they've got
jobs
or they live in their parents basement
still then they're not paying rent and
they can afford some ass
so bad
I'll afford some ass
ads what we got to create like a new
Discord right or a new Channel on the
distractible go Discord that's con like
conspiracy planning or like what what
would you even call what would you
categorize this as helping us promote
this would be no no no no no no this
falls under
yes
helping your favorite Creator no no no
no no no
illegal conspiratory
it's not illegal and it's got a legal
gray area conspiratorial ski we gotta
keep it a secret right we got to keep it
all under wraps because obviously none
of these company people are watching
this stream they will never I've learned
this actually if I talk openly about
literally anything in terms of like
trying to come up with a scheme to beat
the the mainstream whatever yada yada
get into something I can talk about all
I want because I realize they're not
watching my channel so we're going to
nothing we say here is ever going to
leak we this is literally a fact so
we need to come up with the scheme zone
right
don't stop twenty dollars
if you get a five dollar CPM what if you
do like a cheaper ad you can do a video
ad you can do video ads for like
not like
for like 20 like dollars dude uh
starts
at five five dollars for ads on Snapchat
think about think of all the people tick
tock tick tock's gotta have like ads
right damn it
and remember you're trying to promote
the quality of the podcast as a whole
and whatever you draw probably okay
we'll talk about it
we're gonna oh my God we're gonna break
this system we're gonna break the system
we're gonna be Tick-Tock dude that would
be cool Instagram and stuff I can't even
put all these potentials do I need to
come up with like a dance or something
for tick tock and then you can re-upload
them as YouTube shorts when that whole
system gets pushed massively at the
beginning next year yeah exactly exactly
and mixer start saying some audio clips
they can use for ads oh wait go this is
your chance uh wait distractible that's
my favorite podcast
Bob your turn
boy golly gee do I love listening to
distractible while IP
whoopty whoop I can't stop listening to
distractible while I poop
[Laughter]
[ __ ] slippity D listen to distractible
With Me
foreign
Ty Heart of heart I took a big fire it's
Paul Listen to distractible
I can't stop listening distractible
while looking for pump guineas
it's seasonal
Mark you do what like distractibles like
so like good like everyone should like
listen to it like totally
hey wink wonk I heard you like podcasts
I got one back in my place
no no let's go into an illegal
commercial I think oh are you looking
for hot podcasts in your area well
distractible it's right here on your
phone and it's free listen to it ASMR
I don't know whenever I do like random
[ __ ] videos I just always make them
creepy for some reason you know the
latest like go to go to the uh National
Weather system I don't know why
I was enjoyed a directbully time.gov I I
just really like making those things but
anyway this is genius we are not
representing our genius at the moment
but trust me you can put your faith in
us we know what we're doing this is all
a great idea I can only assume the
engine of creation is already spinning
and you guys are just going and going
and using your power to really yeah and
if there's enough good ones we'll get a
compilation of some of your ads and
we'll put it under the distractible page
or like Mark's we'll put it somewhere we
could run use uh listener ads on
episodes as a reward for doing a good
job that is true they hit the audio only
for the episodes unless we put them on
the YouTube we could explain it how many
audio clips
do we have on destructible that would be
great for content on Tick Tock tons
because I I will browse Tick Tock and
like I'll just hear my voice come up all
of a sudden I'm like what the hell is
this and he says like someone took a
snippet which is totally fine do it
that's fine I don't care but with
distractible do it but also Link
distractible in it it's almost like we
should have some kind of distractible
tick tock that makes sounds and tries to
get people to use will you lazy sucker
[ __ ] we got a job for you invest in a
sticker on Tick Tock that looks a
distractible sticker yeah there's
stickers you can embed into your video
that when people push them on Tick Tock
get on that everybody we're too lazy to
do it ourselves yeah we are relying on
you we're all in this together we're all
in this together
but you are all in this together
there's so many every episode probably
has a hundred or so something like that
God yeah uh We're Not Gonna Get The
distractible Tick Tock like that that
would claim probably months ago years
ago
Tyler's calling Mr Tick Tock Mr talk
holy [ __ ] I've not talked to dick in a
while wow tick it's short for
I thought it was timicky
no no no no Timothy talketh anyway I got
I gotta say I'm actually really
impressed by The Audacity Of This
audience uh 84 of them will go evil with
us nice we are going to turn the
advertising World on its head and
therefore it like
disrupt we're going to disrupt the
podcasting World Joe Rogan we are coming
for you how many of you will actually
follow through though I hope a lot of
you do because that'd be really cool to
see that many people in the community
make this kind of content I will check
to see who's talking about it I want to
see an ad campaign I let's let's get uh
who who's the DM of our Discord
he's in charge of that bam
who is the admin I think it's me you are
the primary I can't be bothered
to somebody that I can
make sure oh I'm looking bought against
gaming is there
more pick yeah yep thank you plotting
and scheming okay plotting and scheming
I want to see the plotting and scheming
there's on the distractible go my
favorite sports team combo Discord of
which we it is both because there's
another podcast that we have to also
create in a separate and Camp game and
then we'll create a competitive and Cam
I can't say it ads campaign ad campaign
that will uh Clash would you have to
create a big like competitive thing like
a boxing event we'll make it like a
boxing event Tyler I hate you
wait no you hate uh
wow that just came out of nowhere it's
very rude
no no no we are fighting them
you and me but Mark's on Mark's on our
side right uh yes the home is just
everyone spamming the word plotting
guys you can't just say plotting and not
be it that's not how it works you can't
just plotting it doesn't work in the
distractible
[Laughter]
just everyone plotting scheming plot
plot plot
you have to actually come up with the
the answer to go through with it and do
this anyway what if we all if we all
pull our money together no that's how
the old old ways I was gonna say we hire
an ad campaign this is the ad campaign
yeah this is the ad company this is the
go viral company No One's Gonna See It
Coming
they're already doing it
we also have money we can put in that we
we don't need them to crowdfund we'll do
the big push they do the mini small
pushes they're they're Death By A
Thousand Cuts we're a big stab to the
ass we huh you have something to say the
people get an extra entry into the free
giveaway if they do their own ad camps
right the giveaway oh God guys I don't
want to blow your minds please do I
don't want to blow your mind you've been
so helpful in joining us in evil and
evil shall be rewarded you've been real
bad
but you
you've been so good and good to be
rewarded it seems like this should be
Mark's face
[Laughter]
anyway you've been so bad but being bad
is good now blott and scheme your way
and I'm gonna show you a little thing
listen I'm gonna give you a little
something a little reward you know
you've uh
you've been real good
oh
look at those legs spread there The Edge
the edge
do something very
what does it even look like it doesn't
look like anything what does this look
like to you what does ow what does this
look like to you is this bad what is it
explain Tyler Tyler said this looks like
something bad I know you can't hear him
but what is it
how it doesn't look at all it looks like
a spider I think those are actually
called flop stickers
oh oh I didn't know what the hell we
were talking about this whole time
oh
wait a minute
I was like I was like one more two what
are you talking about
that's a whale tail what do you mean
okay oh fifty dollars is so much ad
scheming oh it's just Canadian dollars
all right Zoom
you've been real good
check this out oh sleep
my God
uh so I gotta say this is this is
something look
Jake Willy I love you to death but
[Laughter]
they said they get they made it such a
big deal that like they had to get this
in my hand to talk about it I'm like
yeah sure you're making a book of like
cool I'll I'll tell people about the
book and they're like no you gotta have
the book in your hand and I'm like oh
yeah I'm the boogie man
hey it's blue it's taped off
it's the right color maybe there's a
paper shortage at least the inside is
the actual book oh yeah definitely this
is like a rough manuscript yeah yeah
yeah they just didn't have the final
cover art anyway so they sent me this
and you know I just think I'm like oh
cool I want to read an excerpt
oh
here's the catch it's not the edge of
sleep yeah because I opened it to a
place
where there's a baseball player I didn't
know about the baseball subplot of the
story
[Music]
orange and blue it's all tied in I just
opened it Vietnam
that winter before I laced on another
pair of spikes I did something I thought
I would never do I was asked if I was
interested in joining the soon to be
commissioner of baseball Bowie [ __ ] Joe
DiMaggio and Philly's pitcher Larry
Jackson on a USO tour of Vietnam
see Tyler it's not World War II it's a
Vietnam sticker
you're the only one left all right
anyway so there's a book coming out
it's a I feel like it's important at
this point to stress
the book is real
this is not just some
bid that markets
There's an actual book in production and
they just couldn't get like a real copy
to mark for whatever reason get back to
edging everyone because it's real yeah
so I think what it was there was a book
and then what happened was it did it
lost in the mail and so they're
panicking
think they just printed this out so some
one person out there has the real
someone does so that's not good why do I
feel like that
Evan did hand this to me
to me you're there wouldn't have it in
hand oh and he was at his printer right
before was he no I don't know oh
no I've been in the car man I'm not
saying that hey I gotta say if Evan did
do that
nice printer
that is a high quality print my man on
the right like weight of paper and
everything it's a real book cover it's
almost like it could have been a real
book cover anyway there actually isn't a
sleep book coming out and just because
you guys have been so good in helping us
plot and scheme let me check the Discord
to see how they're scheming
oh bless John Madden part of the scheme
part of the plot I'm making an animation
right now yes
they did it Evan did it well I knew it
what kind of printer do you have and
then Jake and Willie have got to be like
no
writers have got to be like
how could this happen he just stopped at
the bookstore it's like what book will
fit this cover this one here's the catch
they'll never know it's not my fault it
didn't show up I don't know the mail
gets lost in my house for some reason I
don't know why it's a distractible
Discord oh well how you join it is
doing it do we have a custom link yet
discord.gg slash that thing
distracted know how you joined this I
don't know how you do I've never you
either [ __ ] you can share a link
publicly in places that if someone
clicks it they can join you can invite
someone directly which we're not doing
and also if your server is like big
enough or active enough or both you can
could have a custom link like mine is
discord.gg bobbleheads which is not
really connected to my brand in a strong
way which is kind of an oversight on my
part but there might be a link what do
you have Tyler breaking news breaking
news Pam is available in the field we
have regained connection we've regained
connection with Pam
should I get Pam on the horn probably I
see some real ideas popping up in the
plotting and scheming too
if you want
Pam is her connection is viable at this
currency via sat phone from the
Wilderness of Alaska all right hang on
probably zoom in on whoever's holding
Pam
plot twist it's not Bob or me
all right we're getting this is going to
be very uh
why are we
have to zoom in on Mark
listen I was just trying to reestablish
the connection of Pam in the field for
you
are you sure
oh bam you're alive
hi you're live it's Pam
ham
hi all right Pam you
have to move oh you you survived the the
Moose you survived the Moose encounter
yes I did I did survive the most
encounter I think it's really hard not
to whisper into the guy's ear I was
tempted but uh you know lesson learned
lesson learned I don't want to get
arrested yeah so it was a moose not an
elk
so if they're hunting elk you can
whisper all you want if they are hunting
moose but you just made that mistake
oh it doesn't matter how did you survive
in the wilderness so long
[Music]
and uh survived by a sheer force of will
and cannibalism God I'm jealous of your
job all right well congratulations
hopefully you don't have to revisit
those particular skills again but I have
a sneaking suspicion in your next
assignment you will very soon need that
uh can you can you just tell uh the
viewers out there a quick word of
warning or encouragement depending on
what they need in the circumstance
uh look out for the Moose and be ready
to eat human flesh all right that's
great to hear that's what we expect out
of every distractible listener this has
been Pam in the field
signing off all right Pam leave research
[Music]
sounds like she's got field Madness well
I mean she kind of went into the field
with field Madness so it's not like she
caught it out there sorry
but I feel that field Madness joke just
hit different yeah you know it is hard
field man is very it hits you hard
That's a classic exactly so no okay
we've got the best plan in the world to
promote I'm sure that there are engines
firing up
this isn't probably the most genius idea
we've ever had I think this is gonna I
think this is gonna transcend the world
of podcasting I think so and become the
next
you know like out out there you've got
like first it was Minecraft yeah then it
was V bucks
and Robux these are basically the same
thing yes and then uh dreams face reveal
yes and now this is like this is gonna
be a meme but also the truth
why are you making that face Tyler is
making a face
oh yeah we could do a live Fortnight
podcast recording people people enter
all around the world for that epic games
because I know you're watching Toby
don't listen to No podcast that's that's
like the that's like stages deep into
the genius of this strategy this is
about to change the landscape people
have been talking about web 3.0 and uh
the metaverse and all this stuff no
it's what do we call this what's this
concept I've been trying to come up with
the name grass Grassroots deeper than
Grassroots dirt Roots underground
marketing that sounds like a thing
already yeah the people's campaign
no it sounds like a that sounds like a
weird politics legal case thing yeah
it's crusty campaigns we're so deeper in
the crust of the Earth
the other parts of the earth that are
deep campaign
the mantle mantle wait I've got one yeah
so
people are going to be advertising for
us they're going to be bumping the
podcast right okay I like this
oh sounds meaner now that I'm thinking
about saying it out loud but I'm
committed why would it be me it's chubby
bunkers and they're chunky bunkers
Chucky but chubby bumpers in their
Chucky Chucky trying to say that
phrase is going to get us in a lot more
trouble chubby bumpers chubby they're
chunky bunkers they're chunky is a lot
that's too much it's a role that's cool
that's what's cool now there's a lot of
words and stuff it's not very cool I
think it's cool shadow advertising
that's a cool name now that's cool see
that's cool that's cool I think mine
looks pretty cool I think moose campaign
that's pretty cool
I like Shadow work cannibal campaign
dude liminal marketing we hit the oh the
back rooms oh [ __ ]
yes yes
we're gonna have a back room Bonanza in
a liminal marketing is gonna be great
liminal marketing
trademark right now boom distractible
liminal marketing if we declare
trademark does that count I'm pretty
sure all you have to do is say it out
loud it's especially uh viable if you're
on a podcast whoever the name was
said that first the long gone you know
who you are
that's a hundred dollars it could have
been add money come on marketing post
liminal subliminals no the liminal not
subliminal subliminal marketing super
it's in the space beneath liminals three
liminal it's before a liminal yeah we'll
fix it in pre-liminal marketing yes yes
yes
superluminal marketing sounds cool but
that seems like rename the room in the
subreddit to liminal marketing limitable
marketing headquarters
marketing is more encompassing that's
true this might be the greatest idea
anyway we haven't been talking about the
podcast and why we're great
because it's content first here is it
time for my solo performance of a Bob's
fridge segment can you Tyler has one all
queued up I think oh yeah oh yeah yay
all right this is probably gonna be
really easy and great I I'd had to do
the whole fall on my ass yeah yeah yeah
distracted there's so much pressure on
the Bob's fridge one though yeah yeah
it's a legend
it's too good
oh it seems to be happening already hang
on
okay good we're getting we're getting
set up oh I love this I love the picture
in picture put in theater mode
yes yes nice good nice are you ready I
am are you gonna start the video over
for me
all right
is it big enough for you to read that's
fine
okay okay oh that wait start it over
they appeared higher up before
okay I'm ready and I know where the
subtitles are gonna be now all right
and they can hear us good sick
there we go okay so suffice it to say
finally we learn that we're gonna get a
refrigerator it's gonna come it's gonna
come nine days after it was initially
supposed to be there but whatever but
fine like you know it well fine it's
just not like we needed it right away
it's just a refrigerator this morning I
was literally on a call with you guys
we're getting ready to do exactly what
we're doing right now and my phone
starts ringing and it's the delivery
guys I pick it up and he's like we'll be
there in 10 minutes and I'm like why did
the system tell me 11 or 3 then and he's
like I don't know sir we're on our way
and I'm like this is incredibly
inconvenient can you come at the time
you're scheduled and he was like nope
we're on our way and I literally to you
guys I was like okay I I gotta go I
guess we'll do this later right okay bye
schedules are for nerds
so that's how it starts and they show up
and and I'm like okay so the guy already
really tried to deliver this you guys
can't come in through the front there's
a door it won't fit through so you kind
of have to go around back I'll show you
he's like what do you mean we can't come
in through the front and I'm like we've
been here I'm just saving you some time
it won't fit and he's like no no let me
measure it
fine but also like [ __ ] you like God
damn
so he comes in and he looks and he
measures the little door in the kitchen
and he looks at me easily like oh yeah
definitely not gonna fit through here
and I look at him and I'm like do you
want to see the side yard and like so we
have a fridge in there and it already
has water line because it's as an ice
maker supposed to be some kind of shut
off and these guys cannot find the shut
off to the water line and he looks at me
and he's like well there should be a
shut off you know where that is I'm like
bro I just [ __ ] bought this house can
you call the oh can you call a previous
homeowner again and yeah let me call it
we're bunnies I bought our house and now
we get dinner every two weeks obviously
oh God so he just unhooks the water and
the water is just like
sprayed it takes the line real quick and
he unhooks it and holds it up to me like
I'm gonna need you to hold this and so I
can finish the install and I'm like you
know what fine just do just get the
[ __ ] thing out of here bring the
other one in here and let's do this so
I'm standing in my own kitchen holding a
water line and there's a front window in
the kitchen so I can see what they're
doing and they they take the other one
out and I see them where their truck is
and I see them with the new refrigerator
and they bring it around and so I know
they're like on the way and I'm just
standing there and I just hear from the
backyard like per cheek whoosh and then
one guy goes oh [ __ ] and they just start
rushing around and I just I walk out
there and there's water is erupting up
out of the ground like a geyser has
started gushing and I don't know what
the hell happened apparently what genius
number two did is they had the fridge on
a dolly and there's like a uh Bush and
apparently just [ __ ] destroyed this
bush but also inside this bush is the
PVC pipe coming out of the ground that's
like part of the irrigation system and
what he did was he dragged the fridge
right through the bush and snapped it
off the [ __ ] PVC pipe and what they
were doing one of them wasn't standing
there just staring like thinking and the
other one had the broken off PVC pipe I
was trying to like jam it back on like
it was just gonna slip right back on
and like they looked over at me and were
like apparently the guy who was standing
there watching is the one who did it and
he looked at me and he was like I can't
believe that pipe was in there it was
hidden in there and I just it's an
accident you know and like it's it's not
like a little flower or something it's
like a push it over and Scoot it it's a
big [ __ ] Bush to get the thing
through where he got it through we
literally had to pull it up to that Gap
and it stopped and he was like oh this
bush is in the way and then he was just
like no it's not let's go
this is so fast
and what led them to that action but
there's no version of that that's not so
[ __ ] stupid that it makes me
unbelievably angry
finally I'm like we need to shut off the
water off to the house the guy who
seemed to be in charge of this was like
right right right the water main and he
like handed me the pipe it was like hold
this on there and I'm standing here this
doesn't seem like how you install a
fridge
jeez that was so [ __ ] fast that was
good stuff though that was great I
capture the rage you know during this
actual episode like from my perspective
it was you telling it like having your
moments of like actual anger and then
you're like you're there's nothing like
how you install a fridge and it was just
me like laughing catching my breath and
then laughing uncontrollably and my eyes
are pouring out tears that's why I wish
that like a lot of the podcast is just
like because we do it remotely probably
people don't know we only recently
started actually being able to see each
other with Riverside yeah for these
podcasts but we have never recorded an
episode in the same place yeah like
probably tomorrow will be the first time
that we record an episode of draggable
in the same location we've done all of
this remote because
this guy right here chooses to live back
in
wait
yeah this
this guy it's not even reaching this guy
this guy hey I'll do it for you oh
[Music]
my head this guy right here
this guy right here
chooses to live in Ohio
let that sink in
I'm sorry
oh let that sink in this guy chooses to
live in Ohio instead of being over here
in California where clearly Bob and I
live in the same location having a cool
time yeah having a cool time what do you
have to say for yourself
uh people get gray hair at different
points in their life and pointing out
just makes you an [ __ ]
that's what I have to say what I don't
ever comment uh what do I do about live
in Ohio uh uh I like it there and it's
cheaper did you what happened
I got distracted okay all right cool but
anyway if we get a big fat ad campaign
that shoots us to the top of the charts
a fad campaign
fat ad fat a fat campaign
I think fat ad is short enough okay yeah
[ __ ] my ideas no but
then that means that we can all live in
the Cincinnati house that we have
promised from the get-go of distractible
in Ohio
Ohio
the penthouse was in Ohio
from the days of twitch for me
forever ago what he always said
that we would live together this has
been a dream of ours but we have not
made it possible our significant others
my Mandy and my uh baby everyone one big
house all of us it's gonna be a Content
house yes content house but for podcasts
mostly this is vodka
in wherever makes the most sense for all
of us we're gonna actually equidistant
from all three places
South Dakota we will meet up every day
do you think that South Dakota is equity
Ohio in California where is that point
yes I would guess
so I'm gonna triangulate Los Angeles
slight I would guess somewhere no
Mississippi I would guess somewhere in
Mississippi we'd we would need a uh map
that doesn't account for the curvature
of the Earth because we have to get
exact distances just Google no curvy map
a little no hey Siri no curvy Maps
Cincinnati Los Angeles midpoint no curvy
map I don't live here
Kansas
Lawrence is in Kansas that's where we've
been to Kansas
oh wait our lead race our second in
command researcher Tyler is on the job
yeah Florida is the midpoint you do you
guys even know what a map is who would
ever live in the lower left-hand corner
of Kansas for sure lead researcher Pam
beat second in command researcher Tyler
to the job
in Texas
that doesn't sound right between Los
Angeles and Cincinnati the Central and
San Francisco
can't add a third point this is why your
second in command researcher
hey we're moving to Colorado and Kansas
both of them apparently sounds good
or we can just commute every day
well what always looking for help
getting back
you got this okay
okay
dropped the ball oh you should have kept
going but Tyler should done a better job
too Tyler you should have known that
these cameras have an intersect point
when they that Bob and me CAM have the
same point of intersect
they clearly have a similar intersect in
the center between them haven't you
measured the middle point of these two
cameras obviously if you didn't use
Wade's cam you would have been able to
get away from that constraint
um I'm pretty sure that crust is a very
similar I guess you're just not skilled
enough
wow
wow dude that's weird
I didn't want them to see me grabbing
your fists anyway so
um uh
what do we do now
uh move have we wait I'm gonna check the
numbers so I'm gonna see if people will
actually like us is it working
um viral on Tick Tock with all of your
guys's ad promotions uh what were the
numbers before
I thought you
I thought you were sort of doing that
you're the numbers guy don't you have
the numbers I mean I'm looking I don't
it doesn't mean I know what the numbers
are oh but which number are you looking
at I'm looking at the numbers the like
today numbers
of like listens yeah
um
I sort of I just sort of thought you
were just in charge of that
uh
uh how does it how does it compare to
yesterday
oh
blower
hmm
that seems bad yeah
those are my phone but there's nothing
on here besides social media and I did
this did this endeavor somehow
lose us abuse I mean listens overall I
don't want to say that it did
definitively
I don't want to say that well also you
don't want to not say that it didn't
definitively how do you go how do you
lose a listen
um
did you unlisten deleted the they threw
their phone away
uh I don't have a way to check that I do
I do
um
I do I was on the most successful
episode of that let me see yeah
yeah
we push people away
it doesn't matter here we've pushed we
should um we should do commentary about
drama okay what drama
um uh you guys hate me and you're what's
the topic of of contention
not Ohio
someone made an ad already no way wait
how do we see this what platform how do
we see this
somebody find it somebody's screen
record it someone made an ad all right
like an actual ad like you saw it and it
said promoted in the top corner is that
what it was oh my God if people like oh
my God are we oh we're about to be we're
about to be rocketed upwards on the
charts we're about to be oh we're about
to be launched into the stratosphere
guys where's the ad Tyler's here he's
doing stuff
I found a YouTube video that's called
destructible hashtag ad
that's what was linked to me
you can't just put hashtag ad in it
being ad that's not how it works maybe
that's just a blind upload of it so that
it's watchable without having to
actually get the ad content
s
they're too corporate no I got some
favors I can pull in hey hey look at me
listen you know who you are you know
what I know and you know what I could
tell people that I know so why don't you
just do a little promotion let me do
that
come on
it's really worth it you know the risk
of me saying what I know and you uh
suffering that Fallout
let's just want to just make a little
video
you can wait a few days so it doesn't
seem like so coincidental so
let's just promote distractible a little
bit um
you know what I could do
I'm I I'm so afraid that someone thinks
is gonna think I actually know something
yeah
those to no one in specific or was it
well you could throw some you could
throw some vague facts out there and try
and try and spook some ducks have more
corkscrew-shaped penises
about the the vaguely they vaguely do
don't touch that thing of course crochet
penises
got them they're terrified now I think
they're like explicitly corksured
I know about your Corkscrew penis why
don't you just make a distractible promo
or else quack quack
duck are you back oh my God we don't
want to see him get excited again
remember last time
I don't know he drilled a hole right
through that pouring yes you were gonna
say he opened a bottle of wine for you
nothing
it has been five years since we have
been in the same room doing live stream
together it's true it is true that is
true we have seen each other separately
on occasions in betwixt then yes but not
actually all together and doing this
uh
uh what if I
enticed them
what if I was not so unserious about the
only fans thing
do we have to participate okay is it
like me and Wade fully clothed just
standing watching you get naked or I
mean whatever works of what they want
yeah I don't think that I don't I'm not
gonna speak for Wade I don't think
anyone's too excited about me showing
nudity but I'll participate
and you're the parts that cover mark
I don't want to touch his PP again again
never mind let's do it what if we film
an episode naked and put it on the
distractible only fans whoa
and so we can choose to stay seated or
we could choose to stand up maybe it's
an episode where there's some kind of
physicality to it so you might have to
stand up if you lose or something I like
that I've always wanted something like
that where there was like a some kind of
you're right on this right Wade yeah so
because like we're on a platform that
every time we get something wrong or we
lose a point we start to raise up higher
man my physicality is kind of lost in
this moment Tyler you can sub in for me
on that episode uh you can make it up to
me for me
excellent all right good talk everyone
well it's just defaulting are you
getting tired Tyler are you getting
tired you're tired okay all right you
want to take a break you wanna take a
nap
okay I said it hey Perfect Fit oh new ad
campaign all right Tyler in and out of
his maid outfit there it is yeah what's
the soldier update what's the soldier
update that's not good right they're
never good anymore it's never good
before but yeah now they're really not
serious stuff like crimes no there's
like yeah there's unspeakable crimes
he's being accused of that's sad then
yeah
why did you cut to me when I'm sad
I'm doing the sad this is what people
I'll cry I'll do another crying video
let's do it is sad guys
are you big sad
oh yeah the ads you can never do
we'll give you a real behind the scenes
or like it's it's it's just one of those
things where you can only make so many
better hell pads like we really have
reachable I'm just going to be totally
honest with it like we get it they they
buy a lot of ads and at this point we
have really run the gamut and we started
doing this thing we were just like we're
just gonna
we're just gonna start getting crazier
with the ads and we're gonna see when
their line is we're gonna see where
their Line in the Sand is because we're
just like and then literally one of the
episodes did it actually go out did that
one actually become an ad I don't
remember I'll talk about it straight up
like I think you could talk about it
yeah just because like I started that I
was like guys I got an idea for uh this
uh better help bad read and I went are
you the big sad you got the big
depressive Westies and then literally I
like and then obviously that had to read
did not go through but I don't think
that they listen to him I don't think
that they approve them at all before
they go out so I'm pretty sure yeah
was Guru were the gurus gurus I don't
know yeah they're gurus in there
a few different things I think there was
a guru who better help Ed oh he's made
his way into some various strange places
yeah the
um the mattress the guru mattress
it wasn't there a money one that we did
the guru pit for yeah yeah because Mark
was invested in Pokemon cards or
something I definitely stuffed my head
remember all of the sponsors we've had
yeah I can't even remember half of the
bits that we've had someone has to do
with best my favorite one we did was
like the world was ending one where like
we progressively got into more and more
chaos a lot of people have said that
they like that on the subject that was
so fun but it's hard to do it like that
because like they have to make sense and
also the companies have to all agree to
let you do it
because like the one in the middle does
it and it's just like well now now what
I don't know we can make an ad live for
you chat if you give us a product to
advertise for
but also
I'm just waiting for the like the snap
judgment of clicking let's confuse Tyler
okay well uh
you can't laugh if you're gonna do it
yep
I don't really
one thing that
if you laugh every time
all I do is laugh shut up
okay
oh God the feed froze oh
got him I think cameras weighed camera
blade broke
we had to move a lot less than that
come back well I never know when he's
coming to me oh God the condiment sorry
that's a break
we did with that Wade weird that was
just like the
don't worry son I'll teach you how to
use them my dad's dead can you he never
taught me can you teach me
that was that's what you did without oh
yeah that was the end that was the kind
of man we did when you weren't there
that was it that was it that was
literally it was that I feel like I
don't remember it I think it was my idea
I might be stealing your credit
didn't I just tell you didn't you make a
joke and I was like do that open this
with my dad is dead and I have an idea
yeah yeah that was it the credit I
deserve and therefore we made the
greatest dad no no
charity campaigns when I match donations
except now it's all the companies
matching your Google ads oh it could be
so much more
minutes it's actually accurate that's
accurate
that's buy one get one free
ads
advertisements do it and it's definitely
not evil legal evil legal
yeah exactly legal beagle I don't know
about you because I'm getting hungry
yeah well it's kind of dinner time yeah
it's like almost five yeah it's five
yeah but I want to do a final push here
before we what's the ad we're doing
not mad oh no not the one that's the ad
for us oh this is the district we should
we should workshop and add the way we do
when we do ad reads but we should be for
distractible yeah exactly like we should
have been better into this I know and
not at all self-serving I know right
what if we are you the big sad
big happy
all right come on
come on but now you're all boohoo well
we have the podcast for you who I don't
know if we should con let's put that in
the scrap pile for your ass if you need
an escape from your life well let's be
distracted from the everyday monotony
what are what are our forms are your
parents dead and you need to learn about
the world yeah well our formats are
their dads are dead
and that's hilarious catapult catapult
catapult-based Guru stuff one of us is
insane and or crazy about something
only our thing is marker I caught covid
I heard that
thing uh what else what other formats do
we run uh one of us is uh instead of
being crazy one of us is an idiot and
doesn't understand one of us hates
podcasts
and the other ones have to convince him
to like them pretty much pretty much
uh uh condoms
I am your dad yep
um
those are kind of our formats what other
formats do we have Chad I don't know
Chad what's our script what do we do oh
yeah Mark is doing something on his own
secretly he's a spy or he's right I'm in
a tunnel yeah Mark has a radio voice
yeah exactly
um
I can't talk that was only one but I
really liked that one wow I can't
imagine why
no so it was the better help one where I
was all gibberishy oh yeah
no we don't know I did separate work I
did the better help one because that's
the eyes I snuck in a big sat in that
one
oh God no don't give a super chance
no you people are all stupid it's also
not us it's just smart guys it's just
Mark yes we will never see a dime of
that two hundo that's pretty true it's
gone true Into The Ether extremely true
actually very very much too true but
maybe maybe
well just a sincere ask oh that's your
request okay a sincere request because
we put our heart and soul into this
podcast
and legitimately we only make it because
it's fun for us to talk to each other as
fun for you guys to be a part of it
that's it
that's it and we just want to
be it in the top 10 again and if we get
if we beat Joe Rogan I will start in
only fans
if we get if distractible goes on the
charts past Joe Rogan again I will start
normally fans
he
just want to clarify me
[Music]
we will like the bird a kiwi bird
she is part of we
we I mean Bob's about to have a baby
what does that have this year was tough
on
he just he stole my thing I was about
do I need to change down Cambridge oh
okay I'm speaking for you
now
shut up now look life has challenges for
everybody it does uh this year was tough
uh obviously I don't know what all
you've told everyone in your videos
about what happened with chica but chica
had a rough year our dog Ginger chica
Thunder I'm speaking for you
I'm sorry our dog Ginger had to have
back surgery I'm currently dealing with
a neck and back thing Bob's about to
have a baby there's a lot of things in
life that are making it hard to do like
normal style of our content like
streaming consistently I've not been
streaming consistently YouTube videos
are kind of Hit or Miss but the podcast
is something that is one really fun and
it's also something I think we all enjoy
and we would like to do for a long time
um I think it's very genuine one of the
best parts about that is we are just
genuinely sitting there being ourselves
unapologetically for however long
um with each other because like the
thing about YouTube videos is the game
is fantastic and that's reacting to a
game is great but we don't get to really
just talk to each other about life or
anything when we're doing it it's more
so we're focused on what's going on in
the game live streams I love doing
because it gives me a great time to
interact with my community but again
whenever I'm streaming with other people
live it's not me having a real that
genuine conversation with the people I'm
with and I think the podcast gives us
the ability to do that but you guys get
to listen to me a part of it too and I
think that's one of the many reasons why
we like to do it why we want to start to
do it and why we want to do it for a
long time maybe the rest of our lives
careers whatever
and you guys that do enjoy it helping us
promote and get other people to listen
to it we're not going to force anybody
to stay there it doesn't like it but
people that check it out genuinely seem
to enjoy it and stick around and I think
helping get that out there is good for
us obviously but it's also content where
people will have that if they already
like us and they don't want to listen to
it or check it out because we promote it
people have actually said they're like
you promote it so I don't want to listen
to it it's like yeah let people know it
exists but I just genuinely think a lot
of people would like it and you all
helping spread the word is just one
awesome and two
um helps us obviously and three with the
way life is progressing who knows the
time that it takes to do podcast taking
a day for podcasts is very different
than taking like five to eight hours a
day for streaming and such
all right now you guys can take what the
scratch that left yeah you know what
this reminds me of and we always ended
every tour show
by lining up on stage while sitting on
stage and doing a q a and then saying at
the end we would all get a chance to say
goodbye but we go one at a time and
there was always one of the five of us
on stage who gets absolutely dunked on
and has to go last after everyone else
is like I love you this is the best this
is an honor in the last guys well just
think Mark like you do on stage [ __ ]
well that's that's what made me think of
that because that's what I'm gonna say I
Mark talked at the beginning and talks a
lot I talked to multiple times through
the course of this about how making
things is really satisfying and this is
not some Grand you know thing like Mark
has made lots of cool big heists and and
in space and stuff like that there's
this is a different kind of making but
we are still making something here and
as much as it's been really fun to be a
big part of a lot of stuff that Mark has
made and I feel like really represent
his successes
and this is not a negative thing but
even if I include the tour that we all
did this podcast feels for me personally
more like something that I feel like I
can claim as a success for me it's so
gratifying seeing everyone enjoying it
and this is not a very touching thing
for you but I've I've never got to say
this before this feels like
you all the listeners who actually
listened appreciate what I offer and
what Wade offers and what Mark offers
and that we are co-equal in this because
that Mark Market is huge Markiplier is
huge and that's obviously part of why
this was so successful but
it's very satisfying and it warms my
heart in a very like sappy way looking
at the subreddit and seeing all the cool
images and animations people have made
of us and our stories and our ideas and
it's
I appreciate it on a very personal level
that this feels like a success for all
of us but it also feels like a personal
success for me that we really worked on
this and my ideas are as much of a big
part of the success as the other guys
plus it's fun nothing that is has been
like a huge success has ever been so fun
graduating law school was very
satisfying and I [ __ ] hated it it was
awful but this is like a thing I think
we're all happy to work really hard on
and I'm excited to work hard on it and
we would just really appreciate it if
you would follow and listen and
hopefully you'll enjoy it you'll at
least enjoy some of the episodes I feel
like there's something for everyone in
in almost every episode and there are
definitely some bangers that everyone
probably likes so just you know listen
it's good it's a good podcast I think
beautiful and sincere and there's one
more person here that I think should
speak Tyler how about out here he's
alive everyone that was a very beautiful
and very maybe you pop that seat right
next to Wade there yeah I turned on that
mic
oh look at who it is look at this guy
Ray I haven't officially checked levels
but hopefully I sound fine yeah
so the reason Tyler's also been helping
out is just because also he's very
helpful and he is good to have another
person thank you Bob oh hey Bob
well you could have just taken Bob spot
I didn't have to readjust I thought we
were all going to be here he's just
gonna he's gonna come back he's yeah
making sure my audience not terrible my
levels sound okay Bob
all right my man all right yeah but
Tyler and I we have a competing podcast
so every success that distractible has
is actually detrimental to our own
success and we want nothing more than to
see distractible Crash and Burn and be
destroyed right Tyler take it away I I
came on here to talk about how I enjoyed
distractible I didn't know I was going
to talk about something else oh wow um
that's right you do enjoy it
I am holding him at gunpoint not even
competing here
um no but uh I during kovid
um was around the time when distractible
really started kicking off in a big way
and for those of you that don't know I'm
immunocompromised and so I saw all of
five people in all of 2020. and a lot of
the ways that I kept myself sane and
being able to engage with people because
I'm more of an extroverted person is
that
is that
um
um is that all right we're zooming in my
face uh is that I was able to stream and
interact with the community and
everybody that was out there but one of
the bigger ways that I was able to
engage and be able to connect with my
friends obviously was phone calls but
even then they were busy doing various
other things you know they have lives
outside of just our friendship and I was
trapped in my apartment not to say that
they weren't very accepting but there
were certain points where I didn't feel
comfortable reaching out and one of the
ways that I was able to cope and take
care of like my own mental health in
some capacity and feel like I was around
my friends was to actually listen to
distractible
and so being able to hear them joke and
laugh and and feel a part of that was a
very similar feeling to when I moved out
for grad school and I watched their
content while I was I had moved to
another state and was isolated but this
was a different type of isolation and so
it's it's one of those opportunities in
life where you have something so simple
and free to access
just by pulling up Spotify or any of
these podcast listening apps and being
able to enjoy something and actually
learn little weird tidbits about the
world that I never expected and learn
more about these guys as a whole who are
some of my closest friends and I I'm not
like
shooting the [ __ ] when I say they're the
funniest people that I know
and so being able to listen to
distractible was a huge opportunity for
me to get some enjoyment and feel like I
was with my friends and I think it's an
opportunity for you guys to be able to
find a huge semblance of comedy and
learn like about Minor different things
and obscure facts and different things
that exist in the world and learn more
about them they share a lot of their
personal insights and personal stories
as well and so like some of the things
that were mentioned like I was there for
that like a party that Wade talked about
recently or like um yeah you were
just various things that have happened
on tour different things that were
talked about on the podcast and it was
it was really nice for me to be to feel
that connection and I think it's just a
great
entertainment platform and three of the
funniest people that I know in the
entire world
giving you guys some content that they
work very hard on and created something
so unique and so special for you to
enjoy
that's very sweet I carry go my favorite
sports team so go listen to that instead
oh my God yeah there's also go my
favorite sports team which is a podcast
that I do with Tyler and what makes no
you boys stay right there they're right
there
one of the great things about it is just
like it allows uh Tyler to speak to
something that he is an expert in which
is sports which I am absolutely far
removed from
um so if you if you've listened to
distractible and you're looking for more
content uh definitely check out go my
favorite sports team I'm here uh to
support my friends and to what Bob was
saying before it is really something
that is like it's not mine it's ours and
it's like with go it's not mine it's
ours like everyone is equal part that's
how we divide it that's how it's always
been
um
and so if you want to support like the
podcast you're not it's not just for me
it's for these guys to Showcase their
talents and their ability and everything
that they've done and the fact that you
choose to listen to it just means that
you believe in us and that is something
that is taken for granted these days
especially in the cynical nature that
the internet is it's it's a lot harder
to believe in something when you've seen
so much that has like gone wrong and you
see it every day and if we can provide
even if it's not like long-term
meaningful it's very meaningful for me
to give people some semblance of Joy or
enjoyment
um even if it's a small piece I I feel
in a very large way like I love to make
more things but it always comes down to
just the idea that like I can contribute
just a little bit of joy and these guys
make my life better just being able to
talk with them and the joy that we share
spills over into what you guys listen so
please sincerely do give the podcast a
chance it is quite honestly the
highlight of my week to be able to
record these things
um and I just laughed so hard the
comedic genius that just gushes from
these guys mind I mean that with full
sincerity I think these guys literally
are some of the funniest people tried
really hard to contain it today I'm
sorry if something leaked out
it's okay don't worry you'll be here
next time anyway so we're gonna go get
some dinner uh we're gonna eat uh once
again thank you to the corridor guys for
allowing us to invade their space a
little bit and take this live stream
thank you for everybody out there for
being a part of this and links are in
the description for uh all that we have
talked about uh go check it out we have
more that we're going to do tomorrow
um and uh also yes the edge of sleep
book is a thing
a real book it's really real yes and it
exists or will exist it's not out yet
yeah I'm assuming at the edge of sleep
Tv show uh I I just have to tell you
guys like I am knee-deep into finishing
that show now and it is turning out
really wonderful
um and then my mom's documentary was
announced uh on moment house you can go
and support my mom's dream of owning a
condo in Korea which is literally the
entire point of this uh but it's a lot
of hard work and it is my mom's story
and it is my family story in Korea so on
moment house go there you can check that
out that will be coming up very soon
lots of cool stuff but for now
distractible
go my favorite sports team check it out
I think you'll like it
who's gonna hit this how do we can you
do it on your on your dashboard on your
laptop well I technically I can but you
should stop broadcasting before because
otherwise it'll just cut off at like oh
that's true anyway we're gonna go now
but uh links are in the description
remember if we beat Joe Rogan again only
fans me naked hey
watch our podcast see Mark's penis
everybody wants that what what